तो
चलिए लाइव चलते हैं एंड आई थिंक आई एम
लाइव लेट मी चेक वंस लेट मी चेक लेट मी
चेक लेट मी चेक गाइस सो पहले मैं चेक कर
लेता हूं लाइक लाइव
नाउ ओके सो आई थिंक लाइव आ चुका हूं मैं
चलिए चलिए बहुत बढ़िया सो मुझे एक ब बता
दीजिए आप सभी आय ऑडिबल
विजिबल बता
दीजिए
सॉरी सॉरी गाइस ओके
सो लेट मी नो एवरी बडी दैट माय ऑडिबल
विजिबल गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सबको सबको
दिख रहा है क्लियर विजिबिलिटी सही है
ऑडियो सही है प्लीज बता दीजिए ऑडियो इज
गुड
ओके ओके गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड
बढ़िया ओके लेक्चर में गैप तो रहेगा
लेक्चर में सारे लेक्चर में गैप रहेगा गुड
इवनिंग सबको कितने लोग आ गए हैं यहां पे
14 लोग अभी सिर्फ 14 लोग ही आ गए कहां गए
बाकी सब लोग यार जल्दी से जल्दी से फटाफट
आ जाइए जल्दी से आ जाइए ओके 37 पीपल आर
हियर ओके 37 चलिए बढ़िया अच्छी बात है गुड
इवनिंग सबको अ सबको अ वेरी वेरी वेरी वेरी
गुड
इवनिंग
एंड
एंड गुड इवनिंग सबको एंड विश यू ऑल अ वेरी
वेरी हैप्पी न्यू ईयर बी लेटेड हैप्पी
न्यू ईयर अ वैसे मैंने आपको विश किया हुआ
था तो आज जो है हम स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं एक
बहुत ही शानदार टॉपिक आज हमारी जो है
क्लास सिक्स है हमारा अ बग
बाउंस का एंड यह जो स्पेक्स मैंने लगा रखा
है इसके पीछे का कारण क्या है कि बेसिकली
जो सेटअप होता है मेरा तो सामने लाइट्स
लगी रहती हैं और वह लाइट्स बहुत ज्यादा
आंखों पे जोर डालती हैं तो प्रॉब्लम होती
है थोड़ी सी जब सेशन ओवर हो जाता है उसके
बाद क्योंकि काफी लॉन्ग टाइम तक एक्सपोज
रहता है जो आई है लाइट के सामने इसलिए
मैंने यह लगा लिए हैं ग्लास ताकि थोड़ा
इसको फिल्टर आउट किया जा सके लाइट्स को
राइट चलिए
या बिलेटेड हैप्पी न्यू ईयर तो आज का आपने
टॉपिक तो देख ही लिया होगा आज का टॉपिक
बहुत ही शानदार टॉपिक है मैं आपको यहां
पे लेट मी ओपन द पीपीटी
हियर चलिए एंड वेलकम एवरी बडी जो भी नए आए
हैं जो भी पुराने हैं सबको वेलकम गुड
इवनिंग सबको वेलकम टू द क्लास सिक्स आज हम
शान के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं शडा की
इंपॉर्टेंस को देखने वाले हैं सोडा के
यूज़ केसेस को देखने वाले हैं लाइव करने
वाले हैं सब सबे हर एक चीज़ लाइव करने
वाले हैं एंड कुछ सीक्रेट्स जो शान के
थ्रू यू कैन गेट अ गेट वह हम निकाल के
ट्राई करेंगे निकालने की एक पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट के लिए एंड बग बाउंट में शोन का
बहुत बड़ा रोल है हालांकि शान के
अल्टरनेटिव्स भी बहुत सारे अवेलेबल हैं
जैसे जूई है सेंसेस है हंटर है बहुत सारे
हैं बट सडन का एक अपना क्रेज है एंड शान
को
एवरीबॉडी जर्नी आप उसको यूज़ करने वाले
हैं इस सबके पहले यहां पे पहले मैं एक चीज
यहां पे देख लेता हूं अ जस्ट
वेट आप सबको एक नोटिफिकेशन दे देता हूं अ
सभी लोगों के
लिए ओके तो सभी के लिए मैं एक चीज बता
देता हूं आज के सेशन स्टार्ट करने से पहले
कि जितने लोगों ने अभी जैसे ये क्लास
सिक्स है तो आपका यह हमेशा एक रोल होना
चाहिए हमेशा आपके मन में ये होना चाहिए कि
जैसे ही नेक्स्ट क्लास हो तो उसके पहले की
क्लासेस के वीडियोस आप देख के कंप्लीट कर
चुके हैं टास्क्स जो दिए गए हैं कंप्लीट
कर चुके हैं अब आप में से बताइए मुझे आप
में से कितने लोगों ने टास्क प्रीवियस जो
मैंने दिया हुआ था कंप्लीट किया है
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करने का मुझे बताइए कितने
लोगों ने किया है एकदम एकदम से ऑनेस्टली
बताइएगा एकदम ऑनेस्टली बताइएगा क्योंकि
जिन लोगों ने किया है मैंने बोला था आपको
लिंकन या ली या
instagram2 कुछ बंदों को छोड़कर मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं लेट्स गो टू द लिंक
न एंड लेट्स सी मैं आपको यहां पर दिखाता
हूं यहां नोटिफिकेशन में चलते हैं एंड
यहां मुझे एक नोटिफिकेशन आई
[संगीत]
थी इस बंदे की एंड ही इज सत्य सागर राइट
सो आई हैव गट द नोटिफिकेशन फ्रॉम हियर
एंड सत्य ने कंप्लीट किया है जो रिकॉन का
टास्क था इसने कंप्लीट किया है एंड इसने
टैग भी किया डिफन साइबर सिक्योरिटी मुझे
भी यहां पे टैग किया इसने एंड मैंने यहां
पे इनके पोस्ट को को लाइक भी करा है तो ही
हैज जस्ट अ कंप्लीटेड द टास्क एंड ही हैज
टैग्ड एवरीथिंग तो ये काम आपको भी करना है
गारंटी के साथ बोल सकता हूं यू विल बिकम अ
प्रो बक बाउंट हंटर एकदम फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
कोई पैसा आपको नहीं देना है ठीक है चलिए
तो ये चीज आपको समझ में आ गई होगी
एंड मैंने क्या किया था आज के सेशन को
स्टार्ट करने से भी पहले मैंने आपके लिए
कुछ भेजा था किस कहां पे भेजा था अभी शायद
हमारा ऐप जो है वो सही से काम नहीं कर रहा
है बट कर रहा शायद करने
लगा लेट मी शो यू मैंने आपको कोई चीज दी
थी कोर्स में आपको फ्री वाली जो कोर्स थे
उसमें कुछ मैंने आपको दिया था चलिए मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं मैंने क्या दिया हुआ
था ताकि आपको भी पता चल
जाए
ओके ओके
चलिए
ओके लेट मी शो
यू चलिए यहां पर चलता हूं मैं यहां पर मैं
आपको प में लेकर चलता हूं यहां पर एंड
यहां पर जब आप फ्री वाली कोर्स पर जाएंगे
जो भी इसमें जॉइन है तो आप कंटेंट प
जाएंगे ठीक है कंटेंट पे तो यहां पर आपको
फ्री बग बाउंट रिसोर्सेस में जब आप जाएंगे
तो यहां पर आपको एक चीज मिलेगी शान चीट
शीट ये आपको डाउनलोड कर लेनी है इसको आपको
डाउनलोड करके जिप फाइल होगी उसको अनजिप कर
लीजिएगा अंदर दो चीट शीट मिल जाएंगी ठीक
है हालांकि और भी चीट शट्स है मैं आपको और
भी अपलोड कर दूंगा अपडेट कर दिया करूंगा
यहां पे बट स्टिल अभी के लिए यह कर
लीजिएगा यह आपको जरूरत पड़ने वाली है चलिए
अब पहले समझते हैं शान क्या है एंड शान की
हमें क्यों जरूरत है ठीक ठीक है अब यहां
पे देखिए दो चीजें होती है मैं आपको पहले
समझा देता हूं दो चीजें होती है एक होता
है
डडड एक होता है इंटरनेट ठीक है अब मुझे आप
बताइए इंटरनेट और w डड में कोई डिफरेंस है
कि नहीं है पहले तो मुझे आप यही बता दीजिए
जितने लोग भी यहां पे है प्लीज लेट मी नो
एवरीबॉडी कि डडड और इंटरनेट इन दोनों में
कोई डिफरेंस मतलब कोई की डिफरेंस है या
एकदम एग्जैक्ट सिमिलर थिंग्स है ये लेट मी
नो बताइए जल्दी
बताइए गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग और स्ट्रीम को शेयर कर दीजिए अपने
दोस्तों के बी जल्दी शेयर कर दीजिए आज
सिर्फ 70 लोग ही है यहां पर इट्स नॉट गुड
ओके आपको आना आपको लाइव अटेंड करना है ये
रिकॉर्डिंग के भरोसे नहीं रहना भाई लाइव
के जो मजे हैं वो रिकॉर्डिंग में नहीं है
सच बता रहा हूं मैं
आपको डिफरेंस है या नहीं
है बता दीजिए डोंट नो डोंट नो सेम है आई
थिंक नहीं नो नो सेम है यस सर ऑको डिफरेंस
है चलिए सिमिलर थिंग्स हैविंग डिफरेंट
डोंट नो
ओके चलिए पता नहीं पता नहीं पता नहीं पता
नहीं ओके चलिए तो यह
काम यह काम हम गल से करवा लेते हैं इज देर
एनी
डिफरेंस
बिटवीन
इंटरनेट ए एंड एंड मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
यहां पे एंड डडड चलिए हम
है कि नहीं अब देखिए हम दोनों ने या हम
लोगों ने इन डिफरेंसेस को हटा दिया है
ऑलमोस्ट नेगलिजिबल कर दिया है हमने इन
डिफरेंसेस को
दैट्ची सर्विसेस हैं उसमें एक पार्ट है
wwwbstc2019 ये जो
इसको हम बोलते हैं एथिकल हैकर सर्च इंजन
या हैकर सर्च इंजन आप बोल दीजिए एथिकल
हैकर सर्च इंजन इस सडन को बोलते हैं सडन
एक एथिकल हैकर्स का सर्च इंजन होता है एंड
बेसिकली यह इंटरनेट को क्रॉल करता है यह
इंटरनेट को क्रॉल करता है यह क्रॉल डडड
क्रॉल मतलब स्पाइडर स्पाइडर मतलब कलेक्ट
करना इंफॉर्मेशन एंड यह करता है
क्रॉल इंटरनेट को पूरे इंटरनेट को क्रॉल
करता है शान ये दोनों में यही डिफरेंसेस
है यानी जितने भी इटर पे डिवाइसेज एक
दूसरे से कनेक्टेड या कनेक्टेड डिवाइसेज
है उनको क्रॉल करता है हमारा शान बट
google's फर्स्ट सर्च इंजन फॉर इंटरनेट
कनेक्टेड डिवाइसेज डिस्कवर हाउ इंटरनेट
इंटेलिजेंस कैन मेक यू इवन बेटर डिसीजन
हेल्प यू मेक बेटर डिसीजन ठीक है यह समझ
में आ गया अब यहां पे अब यहां पे यहां पे
देखिए क्या करना है बियोंड द वेब
वेबसाइट्स आर जस्ट वन पार्ट ऑफ द इंटरनेट
यहां भी लिखा हुआ है यूज शोडाउन टू
डिस्कवर एवरीथिंग फ्रॉम पावर प्लांट्स
मोबाइल फ्स रेफ्रिजरेटर्स माफ्ट सर्वर्स
एक्सेट्रा एक्सेट्रा एक्सेट्रा हर चीज तुम
ढूंढ सकते हो एक छोटा सा एग्जांपल अब मैं
पहले आपको एक चीज बताता हूं कि शान का
देखो सडन पे क्या है ना यह फ्री सर्विस तो
देता है बट फ्री सर्विस में यह आपको सिफ
टू पेजेस की रिजल्ट्स देता है जैसे मैंने
कुछ सर्च किया मान लो ठीक है मैंने सर्च
किया
वेबकम मैंने सर्च किया वेबकम मान लो आई
हैव सर्च वेबकम वेबकैम पे सर्च किया तो
टोटल 8872 रिजल्ट्स मुझे आए हैं 8872
रिजल्ट्स आए हैं ठीक है अब मुझे ये सारे
वेबकम्स मिल रहे हैं जो ये आईपी एड्रेस
तुम्हें दिख रही है या जो भी होस्ट नेम्स
दिख रहे हैं ये सारे वेबकम्स के होस्ट
नेम्स या आईपी एड्रेसस हैं अब फ्री अकाउंट
जब होगा आपका बिल्कुल फ्री होगा तो दो
पेजेस के रिजल्ट्स यानी नेक्स्ट एक और
करेंगे और आपका बस उतना रिजल्ट यह आपको शो
करता है बट शान क्या है ना सडन की एक
मेंबरशिप आती है देखो वैसे तो प्राइसिंग
बहुत महंगी है आप इसके पेड प्लान के लिए
नहीं जा सकते हो क्योंकि यह काफी महंगा है
फ्रीलांस प्लान भी है वो सबसे कम वाला
प्लान जो है $69 पर मंथ का है तो यू डोंट
हैव टू गो विद दिस बट इनका एक मेंबरशिप
आता है ठीक है तो यहां पे आप देख रहे
होंगे यू आर ऑलरेडी अ मेंबर अब मेंबर में
क्या है मेंबरशिप में क्या होता है इफ यू
वुड लाइक टू एक्सप्लोर मोर ऑफ द सडन
वेबसाइट्स एंड एपीआई देन द फ्री अकाउंट
प्रोवाइड्स देन चेक आउट द शान मेंबरशिप
इट्स अ वन टाइम पेमेंट फॉर अ लाइफ टाइम
अकाउंट अपग्रेड टू ब्राउज मोर रिजल्ट्स
मॉनिटर सम आईपीस एंड डाइव इन टू द एपीआई
यानी कि ज्यादा रिजल्ट्स चाहिए आईपी वगैरह
मॉनिटर करनी है या और भी एपीआई वगैरह का
काम करना है सब कुछ तो आप क्या कर सकते
हैं आप इसका मेंबरशिप ले सकते हैं अब ये
मेंबरशिप क्या होता है ना सडन के तरफ से
ना टाइम टू टाइम ये लोग क्या करते हैं ना
सडन वाले ये आपको ऑफर में मेंबरशिप दे
देते हैं जैसे मैंने जब लिया था सडन का
मेंबरशिप दैट आई गॉट अ इन $ ल में मुझे
मिला था ठीक है व जस्ट $ तो मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं जैसे आप
[संगीत]
कुछ ऑफर लाते हैं अपनी मेंबरशिप के लिए तो
उस ऑफर में आपको एक या $5 में यूजुअली $50
की होती है मेंबरशिप इनकी 50 के आसपास की
बट यूजुअली उस ऑफर में आपको एक या $5 के
आसपास की मिल जाएगी तो मेरे को जो मिली है
वो बहुत सस्ती मिल गई थी मुझे उसी ऑफर में
मिल गई है मैं आपको अपना अकाउंट भी दिखा
ही देता हूं जैसे मैं अपने अकाउंट पे चलता
हूं एक बार तो आपको यहां दिखेगा कि मेंबर
में मैं यश यहां पे यस दिया हुआ है मेंबर
में एंड शायद बिलिंग में अ कुछ डिटेल्स हो
शायद यहां ठीक है अ यहां पे कुछ ज्यादा
कुछ डिटेल्स नहीं है बट यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं मेंबरशिप में $49 का वन टाइम आता
है मेंबरशिप आपका एंड इसमें आपको क्या
मिलते हैं 100 क्वेरी पर मंथ मिलते हैं
आपको स्कैन 100 मिल जाता है पर मंथ यहां
पे आईपीस मॉनिटरिंग जो आप 16 आईपीस को कर
सकते हैं एंड जितने भी फिल्टर्स हैं सारे
फिल्टर्स आप यूज कर सकते हैं बट वल और टैग
को छोड़ के अब ये फिल्टर्स क्या है इस पे
भी मैं बात करूंगा क्योंकि शन की पूरी
लाइफलाइन इसकी फिल्टर्स ही है इसके
फिल्टर्स के बेसिस पे यू कैन जस्ट यूज शान
फॉर योर रकन थिंग्स फॉर फाइंडिंग सम सी
ग्रेट्स एंड मेनी इंफॉर्मेशन थिंग्स ठीक
है तो ये सारी डिटेल्स यहां पे अब चलिए अब
यहां पे आपको क्या करना है शान पे आना है
एक फ्री अकाउंट क्रिएट कर लेना है आप सब
लोगों को ठीक है सडन पे जब आप आएंगे यहां
पे मैं यहां पे शोडाउन के मेन पेज पे आ
जाता हूं यहां लॉगइन पे आप क्लिक करेंगे
एक अपने
googleupdate.exe तो टोटली फ्री बन जाएगा
मेंबरशिप ले लेंगे तो आप थोड़ा सा अपग्रेड
कर लेंगे अपने आप को एंड देन अपग्रेडेड
थिंग्स आप यूज़ कर पाएंगे सडन के अंदर में
ठीक है थोड़े अपग्रेडेड फीचर जो है यूज़
कर पाएंगे चलिए अब मैंने यहां पे वेबकैम
सर्च किया था अब ये जो वेबकम्स हैं ये
सारे वैसे वेबकम्स हैं जो मोस्टली मैं
मोस्टली बोल रहा हूं ठीक है नॉट ऑल ऑफ देम
आर अनसिक्योर्ड ठीक है कुछ अनसिक्योर्ड
मिलेंगे कुछ आपको एक्सेसिबल मिलेंगे जिसको
आप एक्सेस कर सकते हो जैसे यहां पे एक
कैमरा है बीजी आईपी रीडायरेक्ट करके आप इस
पे क्लिक करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको ये ओपन
होके आ जाएगी अ फिलहाल नहीं ओपन हुआ कुछ
भी चलो इसको ओपन करके देखते हैं तो यहां
पे भी कुछ अ लाइक कुछ चीजें मिल सकती है
वेब कैमरा से रिलेटेड यहां पे चल के देख
लेते हैं अ वी कैन फाइंड समथिंग हियर ओके
देयर इज अ पचे टॉम कैट ठीक
है ओके लेट्स ट्राई टू ओपन दिस वन अ दिस
वन इज आल्सो नथिंग अ दिस इज हां यहां पे
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे आपको ये हनी पॉट
का टैग दिया हुआ है ये क्लाउड में है बट
यहां पे हनी पट का टैग है यानी कि दिस
वेबकैम ये जो आईपी है ये हनी पट है हनी पट
सेटअप करके रखा हुआ है ता कि आप जो है
इसमें ट्रैप हो सके आपकी डिटेल्स वगैरह
यहां पे आ सके तो ये एक हनी पॉट चीज बनी
हुई है अब मान लो यहां पे कुछ फिल्टर्स
होते हैं चलिए सडन की ये वेबसाइट है
फिल्टर्स सर्च फिल्टर्स ये लिंक है आपकी
ठीक है ये लिंक जो है यहां पे आपको सडन के
फिल्टर्स मिलेंगे अब सडन के फिल्टर्स क्या
होते हैं मैं आपको ये बता देता हूं ये
कितना इंपॉर्टेंट है देखिए शान फिल्टर्स
ये क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है जो फिल्टर्स होते
हैं डान के आप इनका यूज करके आप इनका यूज
करके सडन फिल्टर्स का आप जो भी नेटवर्क
में कनेक्टेड डिवाइसेज है उनको फिल्टर कर
सकते हैं व्हाट एवर नेटवर्क डिवाइस देयर
आर यू कैन फिल्टर आउट दैट ठीक है अब देखिए
जैसे कि यहां पे वेबकैम तो है अब मुझे
क्या चाहिए मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि मैं
कंट्री स्पेसिफिक वेबकैम को निकालूं तो
मैं क्या करूंगा यहां पे कंट्री एक नाम का
कीवर्ड लगा दूंगा क्या करूंगा कंट्री अब
यहां पे मुझे क्या चाहिए मान लो इंडिया के
चाहिए मैंने इंडिया किया यहां इंडिया एंड
यहां पे ये वेबकैम तो मुझे अब जो रिजल्ट्स
मिलने चाहिए वो मिलने चाहिए जो जो भी
वेबकैम है वो इंडिया के हो जैसे अभी यहां
पे सिंगापुुर वगैरह कनाडा वगैरह मिल रहा
था अब जो मुझे रिजल्ट्स मिलने चाहिए वो
स्पेशली इंडिया के होने चाहिए मेरे सर्च
फिल्टर के अकॉर्डिंग तो यहां पे मैंने
किया यहां पे कुछ नहीं आया इंडिया के लिए
नहीं आया अब मैं यहां पे चलता हूं यहां पे
पाकिस्तान अ
पाकिस्तान यहां का भी शायद कुछ मिलेगा
नहीं ठीक है तो मुझे यहां का नहीं मिला
मुझे अब मैं क्या करता हूं यूएस कर देता
हूं मैं कंट्री यूएस मैंने डाला एंड यहां
पे यूएस जैसे ही डाला मैंने यहां पे मुझे
यहां पे रिजल्ट्स मिलने लगे अब यहां पे
देखिए लोकेशन में यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स
रिचर्डसन यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स अटलांटा
यूनाइटेड स्टेट मॉरिस प्लेंस यूनाइटेड
स्टेट मियामी ये सारे यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स के
जो भी रिजल्ट्स हैं आपको आने लगे अब जब आप
इनको ओपन करेंगे तो यहां पे देख रहे हैं
कि दिस आर हनी पॉट्स ये हनी पॉट है बट ये
हनी पॉट शायद नहीं है सो लेट्स ओपन अ नो अ
नथिंग देयर अ लेट्स ट्राई दिस वन या सो
दिस वन इज अ अ ओके यहां पे कुछ कुछ एक
वेबसाइट खुल गई है सो लेट्स
अ नॉट डिस्कस दैट वेबसाइट तो यहां पे भी
एक ओपन खुली है यहां पे भी कुछ वैसे ही
खुल गई है यहां पे कुछ भी लाइक व्हाट एवर
यूआरएल वी आर गेटिंग वी आर गेटिंग वेयर्ड
यूआरएल सम टाइम्स ठीक है तो यहां पे
वेबकैम हमें यहां पे मिल गया अब मान लो
आपको क्या चाहिए आपको चाहिए कोई पोर्ट
पोर्ट किसी पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट को आपको क्या
करना है फिल्टर करना है या आपको कोई
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट चाहिए स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट
चाहिए उससे आपको रिजल्ट्स फिल्टर आउट करना
है जैसे मुझे चाहिए 21 एफटीपी पोर्ट के
लिए ठीक है तो मैंने 21 किया पोर्ट 21 कर
दिया यहां पे एंड मैंने एंटर कर दिया अब
जैसे ही मैं पोर्ट 21 करके एंटर करूंगा
मुझे रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे राइट एंड मुझे जो
रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे उसमें पोर्ट 21 जो होंगे
वो मोस्टली आपको यहां पे दिखेंगे पोर्ट 21
वाले जो एक्सपोज होंगे अब देखिए कितने
रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं वी हैव गॉट इतने
रिजल्ट्स अब मुझे ये रिजल्ट्स मिले अब
इसको मैं फिल्टर आउट कर सकता हूं बट ये सब
चीज करेंगे पहले हम इसके सर्च फिल्टर्स को
देख सकते हैं पहले हम उसको देखते हैं
चलिए तो सडन के फिल्टर रेफरेंस पर हम आ
जाते हैं यह वाली लिंक है मैं यह लिंक आप
सबको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं चैट में लेट्स
प्रोवाइड यू इन द
चैट
चलिए लेट्स प्रोवाइड यू द चैट यह फिल्टर
है सर्च फिल्टर्स है शान के आप इनको यूज
करिएगा काफी इंटरेस्टिंग फिल्टर्स है अरे
भैया आ जाओ ये पिन करने का तो मैसेज ही
नहीं आ रहा
नाना ओके मैंने लिंक भेजा है
बट आई थिंक यह पिन पिन क्यों नहीं हो रहा
व्हाई इट्स नॉट गेटिंग पिन ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं चलिए मैंने आपको लिंक
भेजा है आप लिंक दे चेक आउट कर
लीजिएगा अब यहां पे फिल्टर्स लगे हैं जैसे
एक ऑल एसएन अगर आपको पर्टिकुलर एसए से
रिलेटेड कुछ चाहिए तो आप एसए से रिलेटेड
डिटेल्स चाल जैसे हमने
faceb9ok
34 329 34 ये हमने टारगेट का एसएन नंबर
डाल दिया अब एंटर कर दिया अब इस एसएन से
चलिए यहां पे कुछ नहीं आया तो एस भी लगा
देते हैं एए के बाद में यहां पे अब देख
लेते हैं अब देखिए अभी हमने जैसे ही किया
ए ए ए 32 934 यहां पे
facebook.com ये आ गया दिख रहा है आपको
कॉमन नेम से हमें आ गया यह देखो कॉमन नेम
मेटा प्लेटफॉर्म्स ये
598 रिजल्ट्स अब यहां पे देखो कुछ एरर
वाले भी है
[संगीत]
पोर्ट वाइज यहां पे फिल्टर किया हुआ है
पोर्ट वाइज यहां पे रिजल्ट्स आपको दिए हुए
हैं कौन-कौन से पोर्ट कितने सारे पोर्ट्स
जो हैं वो एक्सपोज्ड है यहां पे वो दिए
हुए हैं और टॉप ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस कौन-कौन से
हैं तो ओबवियसली
कि मैं
इसको एटीटीपी स्टेटस या एटीटीपी टाइटल के
उसमें फिल्टर करूं तो मुझे मान लो एटीटीपी
टाइटल पे चाहिए तो एचटीटीपी टाइटल किया
सर्च पे क्लिक कर दिया और मैंने जैसे ही
सर्च पे क्लिक किया भैया मुझे जो रिजल्ट्स
मिलेंगे वो एचटीटीपी टाइटल के अकॉर्डिंग
मिलेंगे यानी ये सिर्फ 1 2 3 4 5 ये पांच
जो है ना टाइटल्स मुझे जनरली इस रिजल्ट्स
में मिल रहे हैं जो टोटल 14 598 रिजल्ट्स
है इसमें ये पांच टाइटल्स हैं हम इस टाइटल
के अकॉर्डिंग इसको फिल्टर भी कर सकते हैं
कैसे भैया अब मान लो मुझे चाहिए कि मैं
सिर्फ ये 5xx सर्वर एरर वाले रिजल्ट्स
मुझे चाहिए मान लो मुझे बस यही चाहिए
कितने रिजल्ट्स है भैया 770 रिजल्ट्स हैं
तो हम क्या करेंगे इसको कॉपी कर लेंगे
कॉपी कर लिया अब हम क्या करेंगे अगेन बैक
हो जाएंगे चलो बैक क्या हो जाएंगे यहीं पे
आ जाते हैं ऐसे नंबर पे आ जाते हैं मान लो
यहां पे तो हमने रिजल्ट्स पहले कितने देखे
थे 14 598 उसमें 700 कुछ थे वो फ वो एरर
वाले हम अब यहां पे क्या करेंगे
अ जो आपका फिल्टर है यह यूज़ कर देंगे
एटीटीपी टाइटल अब यह टाइटल कौन सा देना है
यह वाला 5xx सर्वर एरर यह हमने दे दिया अब
हमें चाहिए सिर्फ यही वाले तो हम ये करके
और सर्च पे क्लिक करेंगे तो हमें जो
रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे 700 के आसपास मिलने
चाहिए देखो 770 जो हमारे पास एग्जैक्ट था
वही मिलाइए तो अब सिर्फ 5xx सर्वर एरर
वाले जो रिजल्ट्स हैं जो
शान के तरफ से पूरे इंटरनेट को सर्च कर
रहे हो पर्टिकुलर होस्ट नेम के लिए या
पर्टिकुलर आईपी एड्रेस के लिए पर्टिकुलर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के लिए पर्टिकुलर कैमरा
के लिए पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस के लिए पर्टिकुलर
किसी भी स्टेट के लिए किसी लोकेशन के लिए
हर एक चीज के लिए तुम कर सकते हो
पर्टिकुलर इसकी सबसे बड़ी खूबी यही है तो
अब वहां जब तुम उसको एक्सप्लोर करोगे
ब्राउज करोगे अभी मैं बहुत सारी चीज
दिखाऊंगा अभी हम अ डायरेक्टरी बट फोर्स
करके भी एक बार छोटी सी एक झलक देखेंगे कि
हम क्या कर सकते हैं एगजैक्टली वो हम
देखेंगे बट यहां पे
देखो ये तुम्हें आ गई अब यहां पे देखेंगे
कि भैया ये क्या एरर है सर्वर साइड एरर है
चलिए यहां पे हमारे वैसे कुछ खास काम का
ये है नहीं बट हां ये सर्वर साइड एरर है
कुछ फ एक्सस सर्वे हमें मिल रहा है इस
आईपी पे हम इस आईपी पे फरदर प्रोसेसिंग कर
सकते हैं फरदर दूसरी चीजें कर सकते हैं अब
मुझे क्या चाहिए मैं चाहता हूं कि मैं ये
फाइव एक्सेस सर्वर एरर है ना अब मान लो
चलो एक काम करते हैं लेट्स डू वन थिंग
अगेन हम क्या करते हैं मोर पे चलते हैं
चलो इस बार देखो क्या करते हैं इस बार
हमने एचटीटीपी टाइटल लिया अ एचटीटीपी
टाइटल कहां गई भैया एडी पर टाइटल ही हमने
ले लिया क्यों
भाई
अ चलिए अ यहां पे एटीटीपी टाइटल प ले लिया
हमने एटीटीपी टाइटल में अभी फिलहाल यह डाल
दिया हुआ है इसलिए यहां पे ये आ रहा है
इसको हमने हटा दिया यहां पे और हमने इसको
सर्च कर दिया ओके तो हमें रिजल्ट्स आ
जाएंगे जो रिजल्ट्स हमें आए थे ओके अब
मुझे चाहिए ना कि यह
ये फैसेट एनालिसिस खुलेगी ठीक है
faceb9ok इसको मैंने कॉपी
किया ओके सो देयर इज एन ऐड तो मैं इसको
थोड़ा वेट कर लेता हूं ठीक है चलिए अब
यहां पे हमने कॉपी कर लिया अब हम यहां पे
यहां पे जो हमने डाला था था सिमिलर जो
हमने डाला था वो सब चीज डालेंगे कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है हम यहां पे सेम कीवर्ड
डालेंगे अब हम यहां पे ये वाली चीज डाल
देंगे जो हमें यहां से हटाना है मान लो
जो रिजल्ट्स है मैंने इनको भी हटा दिया
ओके वी रिमूव द एरर अगेन मुझे एक और हटाने
हैं कौन सा हटाने हैं फाइव एक्स एक्स ये
वाली जो है ना ये भी हटाने है मुझे ये
क्यों चाहिए यार ये सवे एरर की क्यों
चाहिए आई डोंट नीड इट तो फिर सोचोगे सर
कुछ बचा ही नहीं अरे कोई बात नहीं यार हम
सीख रहे हैं कोई बात नहीं वी आर लर्निंग
ओके ओके तो हमने इसको भी मान लो हटा दिया
अब हम रिजल्ट्स जो करेंगे तो हमें
रिजल्ट्स में क्या एक दो दो अ 300 के
आसपास रिजल्ट्स हमें मिलने चाहिए मेरे जो
भी रिजल्ट्स है उसके अकॉर्डिंग तो यहां पे
फ एरर आई
थिंक दे
समथिंग ओके लेट्स रिमूव दिस वन लेट्स
रिमूव दिस वन इसको हटा देते हैं कुछ
ज्यादा हमने माइनस कर दिया सो मे बी अच्छा
अच्छा यहां पे एक चीज हटा दी एक चीज हमने
डबल ज्यादा दे दिया था अब रिजल्ट्स आ जाने
चाहिए ओके सो वी गट हियर सो हमें क्या
क्या मिला 93 कुछ रिजल्ट्स यहां पे मिल गए
हैं हमें तो वो जो जितने थे वो हट गए यहां
पे एक और एरर ये लगा के अब अब करते हैं अब
शायद कम आएंगे नाउ लेट्स सी द
रिजल्ट हमने एक और लगा दिया यहां पे जो
पहले हमने लगाया था लेट्स वेट फॉर द
रिजल्ट या सो हमें ये रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं
मान लो तो हमें अब रिजल्ट्स जो है और भी
शॉर्टेड रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं अब हम इन
रिजल्ट्स को भी चेक आउट कर सकते हैं कि इन
पर्टिकुलर आईपी एड्रेसस पे क्या लिस्टेड
है क्या है क्या नहीं है ये सारी चीज देख
सकते हैं देखो सो दिस कंटेंट इज नॉट
अवेलेबल राइट नाउ हम इस पे डायरेक्टली
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करके ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं कि इसके अंदर भाई क्या है क्योंकि है
तो ये मेटा प्लेटफॉर्म का ही आईपी एड्रेस
ठीक है तो भाई ये हमारे लिए बहुत ज्यादा
यूज़फुल है तो हम हर एक आईपी एड्रेस को ना
स्कैन करेंगे डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्स करके
ट्राई करेंगे आगे हम जबजब हम जैसे-जैसे बग
बाउंट में हम आगे बढ़ेंगे ना हम बहुत सारी
चीजें करेंगे तो हम वहां पे डायरेक्ट वड
फोर्सिंग वगैरह चीज करेंगे अब मान लो
तुम्हे
[संगीत]
facebook.com प चलता हूं चलो तो आपको कैसे
फाइंड करना है ये आप जाओ facebook.com के
या जो पर्टिकुलर जो भी डोमेन है उस परे
चले जाओ ठीक है अब यहां पे आओगे अच्छा
मुझे एक बात बताओ यार आप लोगों को समझ में
आ रहा है ना सारी चीजें यह चीज समझ सम आ
रही आप लोगों को लेट मी नो गाइस
इंटरेस्टिंग लग रहा है आपको आपको समझ में
आ रहा है यह कितना शानदार ची शोडाउन अभी
मैं और बहुत सी चीज बताऊंगा पहले बताओ
मुझे समझ में आ रहा है मजा आ रहा है कि
नहीं आ
रहा मजा आ रहा है एवरीवन लेट मी नो सभी
लोग रिप्लाई कीजिए यहां पर 90 लोग से ऊपर
लोग हैं कम से कम रिप्लाई यार मार दो यार
रिप्लाई
यार चलिए यस सुनील संग यस ठीक है मैं देख
रहा हूं
समझ में नहीं आ
रहा यू आर नॉट गेटिंग दवाज आर यू नॉट
गेटिंग समझ नहीं आ रहा क्या बताइए मुझे
इंटरेस्टिंग यस यस यह आपके रेकन में काफी
हेल्प करेगा याद
रखिएगा
ओके ओके कुछ लोगों को नहीं आ रहा होगा टू
मच फन ठीक
है
ओके
ठीक
है चलिए तो कुछ लोगों को नहीं भी समझ में
आ रहा कोई बात नहीं आप लोग समझ जाएंगे
टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है ठीक है ज्यादा
आपको टेंशन नहीं लेना है पहले से जल्दी से
लाइक कर दो वीडियो को यार शेयर कर दो
दोस्तों के बीच ठीक
है सडन का सिंपल सा सडन एक हैकर सर्च इंजन
होता है जहां पर आप इंटरनेट पे जो
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट और रेकन में आपकी काफी
हेल्प करता है अभी कैसे हेल्प करेगा अभी
आप भी और भी आगे देखेंगे हम प्रैक्टिकली
अभी देखते जाएंगे तो ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं
लेना है ठीक है तो अभी देखते जाइए अभी
देखते जाइए यहां पे facebook.com है यहां
पे अब हम क्या करेंगे यहां पे इस वाले पैड
लॉक पे क्लिक करेंगे देखो जो भी मैं आपको
करा रहा हूं बग बाउंट में बहुत ही लाइन
लेंथ के थ्रू मतलब बहुत ही अरेंज्ड वे में
करा रहा हूं रिमेंबर ट बहुत ही अरेंज्ड वे
में और इस अरेंज्ड वे में जब मैं करा रहा
हूं तो आप इसी अरेंज्ड वे में में चलिए अब
मैं अगर कुछ और करा रहा हूं आप कुछ और
बोलेंगे तो वो नहीं हो वो पॉसिबल ही नहीं
है फिर वो तो फिर हॉच पच हो जाएगा ना कोई
मतलब ही नहीं है गिट रेकन भी आएगा और भी
टॉपिक्स आएंगे सारे आएंगे बट एक फ्लो में
आएगा एक रकी में आएगी तो आपको ज्यादा मजा
आएगा अगर आप र्की में नहीं चलेंगे ना तो
आपको मजा नहीं आने वाला है एकदम मैं आपको
सच बता रहा हूं सो प्लीज बी इन अ हायरा की
जैसे मैं करा रहा हूं वैसे आप कीजिए आपको
ज्यादा मजा आएगा ज्यादा कुछ सीखने को
मिलेगा कम टाइम में ठीक है
प्लीज
ओके
ओके सर फिल्टर समझ नहीं आ रहा फिल्टर का
मतलब होता है सिंपली आप उसके थ्रू सर्च कर
रहे हैं रिजल्ट्स फाइंड कर रहे हैं और कुछ
भी नहीं है फिल्टर ठीक है रिजल्ट्स फाइंड
कर रहे हैं और कुछ भी नहीं जैसे ये
फिल्टर्स है ये फिल्टर जैसे एसएन
पर्टिकुलर एसएन नंबर वाले सर्विसेस को
आपको रिजल्ट्स देखने आपको लिस्ट करने है
तो ए यूज कीजिए पर्टिकुलर सिटी के लिए
सिटी कंट्री के लिए कंट्री डिवाइस के लिए
डिवाइस ये सारी चीजें ठीक है ये सारी
चीजें आप कर सकते हैं
ओके ओके चलिए वो सब चीजें आप इधर ध्यान दो
इधर ध्यान दो जल्दी से अब यहां पे
facebooklogin.com ये मिलेगा अब यहां पे
आप एक सर्च फिल्टर यूज कर सकते हैं इनके
इनके अकॉर्डिंग एसएसएल की अब जैसे देखो
मैं एक एसएसएल का सर्च फिल्टर लगा रहा हूं
ठीक है सिंपल एसएसएल काट अ सर्च फिल्टर
लगा रहा हूं किस तरीके से लगाएंगे यहां पे
यहां जाएंगे मैं यहां पे डालूंगा एसएसएल
यहां पे मैं कॉलन डालूंगा एंड मैं यहां पे
अ यहां पे डालता
हूं और ऑर्गेनाइजेशन मेटा platform.in ठीक
है तो मैंने क्या किया यहां पे डाला मेटा
प्लेटफॉर्म्स डट
आईएसी ये डाल दिया हमने चलिए बहुत बढ़िया
अब हम एंटर करेंगे और देखते हैं रिजल्ट्स
हमें कितने रिजल्ट्स मिलते हैं इसके अंदर
में यानी कि मेट प्लेटफॉर्म सांसी जो जो
भी ऐसी सर्विसेस जिसका सर्टिफिकेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यानी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन मेटा
प्लेटफॉर्म सांसी होगा जिसको सर्टिफिकेट
इशू की गई होगी वो सारे यहां लिस्टेड हो
जाएंगे अब आप जब देखेंगे तो यहां देखेंगे
यहां पे कितने मिलियंस में यहां पे आपको
रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं बट हमें भैया इतने
ज्यादा रिजल्ट्स में नहीं चाहिए हमें इतने
ल्स में हम क्या करेंगे यार तो हमें इसको
फिल्टर आउट करना है तो फिल्टर आउट करने के
लिए स्टन का एक बहुत अच्छा फिल्टर है
एसएसएल का देखो मैं दिखाता
हूं एंड दिस फिल्टर
इज
sss.com अब हमें यूआरएल दे देना है तो
हमें पर्टिकुलर एक यूआरएल के लिए जिसको हम
टारगेट कर रहे हैं हम उस यूआरएल को टाइप
कर सकते हैं एंड यहां पे हमें अब जो
रिजल्ट्स मिलने चाहिए वो मिलने चाहिए
facebook.com सए से रिलेटेड ओनली नॉट कि
सारा मेटा प्लेटफॉर्म क्योंकि हमारा सीएन
कौन सा है सीए देखो कॉमन नेम facebook.com
गॉट
इट facebook.com तो अब हम चलते हैं यहां
पे facebook.com एंटर करते हैं एंड लेट्स
सी द
रिजल्ट्स
ओके क्या आ रहा है ओके हमने यहां पे
इनवर्टेड कॉमा यहां प डबल डबल कोट को बंद
नहीं किया
था अब हम सर्च करते
हैं अब
देखा रिजल्ट्स आ गए
ओके तो हमें रिजल्ट्स मिले
5632 अब ये जो है तुम इनके जब सीएन में
देखोगे कॉमन नेम में तो तुम्हें फ दिखेगा
सो बेसिकली वी आर हंटिंग ऑन फ और आवर ओन
टारगेट जोरा हमारा टारगेट था एंड हमें अभी
ये रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं अब हम इन पे फर्द जो
भी प्रोसेसिंग है वो कर सकते हैं जैसे हम
एक एक आईपी को चेक कर सकते हैं ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग कर सकते हैं समथिंग समथिंग राइट
अब या फिर वेब आर्काइव पे हम पर्टिकुलर
किसी एक एक पर्टिकुलर हम लाइक डोमेन का
एंड पॉइंट खोज सकते हैं वो भी हम कर सकते
हैं चलिए मैं यहां पे देखता हूं जैसे यहां
पे डोमेन देखिए यहां पे facebook.com
facebook.com facebook.com
एक्टन क यह भी आ रहा है एक्सटर्न नाम का
एक सब डोमेन का भी आया हमारे पास नीचे
जाते हैं facebook.com यहां पे हैलेट यहां
देखो
sec.com ऐसे बहुत सारे आ रहे हैं हमारे
पास अब ये एरर वाला है इसको भी ओपन करके
देख लेते हैं एडवांस में चलते हैं यहां पे
एक्सेप्ट द रिस्क एंड कंटिन्यू समथिंग
वेंट रॉन्ग ठीक है अब मुझे इसमें से
फिल्टर करना है भैया अब फिल्टर करना है तो
क्या करूंगा मैं मैं मोर पे क्लिक करूंगा
आई विल क्लिक ऑन द
मोर अब यहां पे हम एचटीटीपी टाइटल के थ्रू
फिल्टर करेंगे चलिए एचटीटीपी टाइटल से
फिल्टर करते हैं
एडीपी टाइटल देखते हैं कितने टाइटल्स आए
हैं कितने सारे हमें टाइटल्स मिले हैं
जिसमें से कुछ हमें कुछ ऐसा कुछ वल्नरेबल
कुछ मिलता है क्या कुछ ऐसा देखो देखो देखो
यहां पे हमें मिले रिजल्ट्स में क्या एरर
आ रहा है
जहां पे होता तो है फॉर्ब एक्सेस इज
डिनाइड जब फॉर्ब एक्सेस इज डिनाइड लिखा हो
इसका मतलब क्या होता है आपको क्या लगता है
मुझे चैट में बताइए जब कहीं किसी वेबसाइट
का एसटीडीपी स्टेटस 200 है इसका मतलब ओके
है आप उसको एक्सेस कर पाएंगे अगर 403 फॉर
बिडेन एक्सेस इज डिनाइड का मतलब यह होता
है कि उस वेबसाइट पे उस पर्टिकुलर सर्वर
पे उस पर्टिकुलर आईपी पे कुछ ना कुछ तो है
जिसका एक्सेस आपके लिए ब्लॉक्ड है क्योंकि
आप अनऑथराइज्ड हो आप ऑथराइज्ड यूजर नहीं
हो यू आर नॉट इंटेंडेड टू एक्सेस दैट
पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन ऑन दैट सर्वर तो यहां पे
इंटरेस्टिंग होती है 403 बायपास करने का
आप ट्राई कर सकते हैं यू कैन ट्राई फॉर
बायपासिंग 403 एरर एंड यू कैन ट्राई टू
गेट एक्सेस टू दैट पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स एंड
जब आप इस तरह का रिसोर्स को एक्सेस कर
लेते हैं तो मोस्टली वो सेंसिटिव होता है
p1 प2 कैटेगरी में आपका फॉल कर सकता है
एंड एक अच्छी खासी बाउंट भी आपकी लग सकती
है जब ऐसे कुछ आप निकालते हैं तो ये बहुत
ही एक शानदार चीज है 4034 बिडेन आप देख
रहे हैं यहां पे ये दोनों बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है दो यहां पे मिले आपको
दो रिजल्ट्स एंड एक रिजल्ट इसका है फम योर
अकाउंट कुछ खास का नहीं आएगा हमें एंड
यहां पे हमें कंट्रोल ये क्या आ रहा है
कंट्रोलर पॉ f.n. ब ये भी कुछ कुछ है कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग ये है तो हम इसको एक कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग डिफरेंट तो ये लग रहा है मुझे
तो एक बार हम इसको देखते हैं क्या है ये
कुछ है भी कि नहीं मैंने इसको कॉपी किया
यहां पे एटीटीपी
अ कॉलन एटीटीपी डॉट टाइटल सॉरी एटीटीपी ड
टाइटल कर दिया हमने कॉलन एंड वी गिवन दिस
वन एंड दिस वन ठीक है अब हम एंटर करते हैं
एंटर करते हैं एंटर करते ही हमें यह वाला
रिजल्ट मिल गया जो एक रिजल्ट हमें हमने
फिल्टर आउट किया था एंड दिस इज कंट्रोलर
f.n.
ब्रजल ब्राजील का यह कोई लोकेशन है एंड
यहां
पे कॉमन नेम तो facebook.com है बट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इज डिफरेंट कोई बात नहीं एक
बार देखते हैं क्या है सो वी विल एक्सेस
एंड दिस इज ओके दिस इज आईपी कंट्रोल पैनल
अ जहां तक समझ में आ रहा है दिस इज आईएसपी
कंट्रोल पैनल तो देखा आपने एक आपको एक ना
लॉगइन पैनल मिला यू गॉट इट हियर आपको एक
लॉगइन पैनल तो मिला भैया अब इस लॉगिन पैनल
पे तुम एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन के ट्राई कर लो
इस लॉगिन पैनल पे तुम एक्सएसएस के लिए
ट्राई कर लो इस लॉगइन पैनल पे तुम अ लाइक
आईआर के लिए कुछ अ लाइक डायरेक्टरी सॉरी
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कर लो लाइक यू
कैन ट्राई डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़
थिंग्स इस पर्टिकुलर आईपी पे यू कैन ट्राई
डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स एंड वहां
से कुछ ना कुछ आपको मिल सकता है
ठीक है यह समझ में आ गया यह समझ में
आया यह कितना शानदार चीज है तो आपको कुछ
डिटेल्स तो मिल रहे है ना भैया इसको पकड़ो
इसको रखो इधर साइड में इसपे कुछ करेंगे हम
वी विल डू समथिंग ऑन दिस ओके तो यह हमें
एक चीज मिल गई तो इस तरीके से यू कैन
फिल्टर आउट थिंग्स आप सडन का यूज कर सकते
हो एसएसएल सर्च सब्जेक्ट सीएन इसे आप
पर्टिकुलर होस्ट नेम के लिए कर लो और फिर
एसटीडीपी टाइटल से फिल्टर आउट हमने किया
था वो हमने कर दिया अब मुझे चाहिए मैं कोई
और भी इसमें फिल्टर लगा के सर्च कर सकता
हूं जैसे मुझे
चाहिए लाइक कोई से भी फिल्टर लगा
लो स्क्रीनशॉट वाली फिल्टर लगा सकते हो
अ एनटीपी आईपी एनटीपी पोर्ट के लिए लगा
सकते हो हैश के लिए लगा सकते हो फकॉन के
लिए लगा सकते हो डोमेन के लिए भी लगा सकते
हो लाइक इफ यू वांट फिल्टर विद द डोमेन तो
आप डोमेन के लिए भी आप फिल्टर आउट कर सकते
हो facebook.com के लिए जो भी रिजल्ट्स आए
उसमें डोमेन के लिए पर्टिकुलर फिल्टर कर
सकते हो जैसे मुझे यहां पे मिला तो ये
पर्टिकुलर जो है आपके जो रिजल्ट्स मिले
हैं 5632 उसमें से ये डोमेन वाले जो है ये
सारे डोमस के भी रिजल्ट्स आपको मिले हैं
इन सारे डोमेन से आपको रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं
ठीक है ये सारे डोमस से ये सारे डोमेंस
कहीं ना कहीं किसी ना किसी तरह से
स्टेटस तो स्टेटस चल लेते हैं भैया
कौन-कौन से स्टेटस कोर्स वाले हमारे पास
अवेलेबल हैं 404 है कि नहीं है ये देखो ये
है 400 वाले हैं 200 वाले भी काफी हैं 500
वाले हैं 403 फॉर बिडेन वाले हैं आपके एंड
404 वाले भी हैं 404 सब डोमेन टेकओवर वाली
चांसेस हैं भैया आपके तो हम क्या करते हैं
ना एसटीडीपी स्टेटस 404 वाले भी ट्राई मार
लेते हैं भैया क्या हमारा क्या आ जाता है
तो यहां पे कर लेते हैं
[संगीत]
http1 एंड 404 तो 404 वाला एंटर करते हैं
देखते हैं क्या हमें रिजल्ट्स मिलते हैं
दो रिजल्ट्स हैं शायद दो मिलेंगे दो हमें
मिल गए हैं 404 वाले मिल गए हैं ठीक है वी
गॉट द 44 रिजल्ट्स एक हमें यहां मिला है
व्हाट इज दिस अ देखते
हैं 404 नॉट फाउंड ठीक है कुछ है नहीं ओके
कोई बात नहीं है यहां भी देख लेते हैं अ
कोई पेज होस्टेड मिल जाए वैसे तो हम चेक
कर सकते थे बट ठीक है रिसोर्स वाज नॉट
फाउंड ठीक है तो हमें कुछ नहीं मिला यहां
पे फरदर हम और भी टेस्टिंग वर बहुत सारी
चीजें कर सकते हैं दैट डिपेंड्स ऑन अस बट
यहां पे हमें एक सब डोमेन जरूर मिल चुका
है सब डोमेन क्या है . facebook.com ये एक
सब डोमेन मिला है l.f. क ये काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग हो सकता है . facebook.com
देखो वी आर हैविंग ट्रेवल ट्रबल हमें इसे
एक्सेस करने में ट्रबल हो रहा है कोई बात
नहीं है ट्रबल हो रहा है कोई बात नहीं है
लेट मी पिंग लेट मी पिंग इट इज इट
पिंगबल नो अ पिंग नहीं हो रहा है कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आईएपी आईसीएमपी भी ब्लॉक हो
सकती है अगर नहीं हो रहा है तो दैट नॉट एन
इशू अब हम इस पे ना डायरेक्टर ब्रूट फोर्स
कर सकते हैं भैया वी कैन ट्राई डायरेक्टर
ब्रूट फोर्स ऑन दिस अब भैया ये कैसे चीज
करें मतलब हम इसके अंदर की कुछ हिडन चीजें
निकाल सकते हैं अगर कुछ है तो अब इसके लिए
एक टूल आती है एक टूल नहीं बहुत सारी टूल
आती है डीआई आर बस्टर आती है डीआईआरबी आता
है गो बर आता है डायरेक्टरी डीआई आर सर्च
टूल आती है अ अ डब्लू फज से आप कर सकते हो
आप एफएफ यूएफ से कर सकते हो न्यूक्लि के
टेंपलेट्स यूज कर सकते हो यू कैन ट्राई
डिफरेंट थिंग्स मैं यहां पे ली पे चलता
हूं मैं एक चीज करता हूं मैं यहां पे लॉग
इन कर लेता हूं मैं अभी बस ये यूज़ कर रहा
हूं आपको मैं डिटेल में बताऊंगा सारी
चीजें टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है आपको जब हम
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग अभी हम पढ़
नहीं रहे हैं डायरेक्ट ब्रूट फोर्सिंग पे
आएंगे तो हम उसको पढ़ेंगे तो टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है मान लो मैं एक टूल यूज़ कर रहा
हूं एफएफ यूएफ दिस टूल इज वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग फॉर डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्सिंग
एंड ये आपके रिपोजिटरी में इंक्लूडेड है
काली के तो प लिस्ट करेंगे एएफ यूएफ तो
आपको यहां पे मिल जाएगा इंस्टॉल ऑटोमेटिक
ऑटोमेटिक इंस्टॉल है भैया तो एफएफ यूएफ
नहीं आती है मुझे यूज़ करने हाफ दे दूंगा
और इसको देखूंगा इसके हेल्प फाइल को अब
यहां पे ऊपर में जाइएगा सबसे यहां पे लिखा
हुआ है ऑलरेडी कैसे यूज करना है फज फास्टर
यू फूल वर्जन 2.1.0 डेव तो मतलब ये हमें
फुल भी बोल रहे हैं भाई अब बताओ तुम यूज़
करोगे क्या एफएफ यूएफ तुम्हें फुल भी बोला
जा रहा है ये टूल के जो डेवलपर हैं जो भी
डेवलपर है हमें बोल रहा है कि फास्ट करो
फजिंग फजिंग मतलब वही कंटेंट डिस्कवरी
मतलब किसी वेबसाइट पे किसी यूआरएल पे किसी
आईपी पे कंटेंट हिडन कंटेंट को निकालना
उसको उसको फाइंड करना फजिंग कहलाता है
कंटेंट डिस्कवरी कहलाता है या डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग आप बोल लो व्ट एवर यू कैन
से अलग-अलग नेम से यह बोल र फूल आप यूज
करोगे क्या
भाई बताओ
भाई यह तो हमें फूल बोल रहे हैं हम इस टूल
को यूज करेंगे क्या या तुम्हे यार तुम्हें
भी बोल रहा है फूलय फज फास्टर यू फूल मजा
आ रहा
है
हां डायरेक्टरी ब् कोई से भी यूज कर लो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोई टेंशन नहीं है कोई
टेंशन नहीं है कोई से भी यूज कर लो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है व्हाट एवर ठीक
है तो अच्छा फूल बोल फूल बोल रहा है तब भी
करेंगे है ना
हां तब भी तब भी करेगा ऐसी कोई बात नहीं
है नथिंग ऐसा कुछ नहीं है आप अगर सही से
यूज करते हो किसी भी टूल को देन यू कैन
यूज इट इन अ मोर गुड वे आप अच्छे से बहुत
ही डीप यूज कर सकते हो उसको कोई बढ़िया से
यूज करो थ्रेड का अच्छा यूज करो ठीक है ना
एंड टाइम आउट वगैरह यूज कर लो अच्छे से
देन यू कैन अ स्केप द फायरवॉल्स एंड ऑल
ओके तो अब यहां पे हम क्या करते हैं एफएफ
यूएफ यूज कर लेते आप डायरेक्टरी आप डीआई
आर सर्च भी यूज कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
डीआर सच इज आल्सो माय वन ऑफ माय फेवरेट
टूल ठीक है तो चलिए तो हम क्या करते हैं
एफएफ यूएफ हान य दे देते हैं यूआरएल के
लिए एंड हमने यहां पे यूआरएल पेस्ट कर
दिया जो हमारा यरल है चलिए लेट मी
सी या तो हमने यहां पर हान य यहां पर
यूआरएल यूज कर लिया एंड वी वी वी विल गो
एंड ी विल गिव दिस यूआरएल आई थंक दिस
यूआरएल इ एटीटीपी और एटीपीएस लेट मी
सी वेर द
यूआरएल
ओके
चलिए देख लेते हैं य पर कॉपी एंड लेट्स
ट्राई टू
फाइंड ओके ओ मंड इट्स इट्स लो मंड इट्स
नॉट ओ म इट लो म ओके आई थ यही है ना हमारा
लो face.com राइट लो face.com दिस वन इज द
यूआरएल लेट्स प्रोवाइड द यूआरएल हियर एंड
यहां पर आपको कोई भी टूल नहीं यूज करनी
आती है कोई बात नहीं उसकी हेल्प फाइल देखो
यूज करो इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना है तो हमने
यहां पे यूआरएल दे दिया एंड उसके बाद हमें
एक वर्ड लिस्ट यूज कर लेनी है भैया वी हैव
टू यूज अ वर्ड लिस्ट वर्ड लिस्ट कहां से
यूज करेंगे यूआरएल के आगे जब आप यूआरएल दो
तो उसके आगे एक कीवर्ड लगाना पड़ता है स्ल
एफ य जड फज एफ यूडल जड फज मतलब इसी पे आप
पर्टिकुलर पे वहां पे फजिंग करो आप इसके
आगे जो भी है लगाना है आप लगाओ एंड फज करो
उसके बाद हान डब् से वर्डलिस्ट दे देंगे
तो वर्डलिस्ट के लिए मैं यूज करूंगा यू आर
यूएसआर देखो वर्ड लिस्ट आपके काली में
कहां पर होता है मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
वेयर ऑल द वर्ड लिस्ट आर प्रेजेंट इन योर
काली एक डायरेक्टरी होती है यूएसआर के
अंदर जाइए शेयर के अंदर जाइए यहां सर्च
कीजिए वर्ड लिस्ट यहां जाइए वर्ड लिस्ट
वर्ड लिस्ट के अंदर जाइए यहां पे यू विल
फाइंड अ लॉट लॉट ऑफ वर्ड लिस्ट कोई सा भी
वर्डलिस्ट यूज कर लो भैया कोई दिक्कत नहीं
आप डीआर बी का यूज कर लो डीआर बस्टर का
यूज कर लो जो भी चाहते हो यूज कर लो तो
मैं क्या यूज करूंगा
अ र बी का यूज कर ले कोई एंड व्ट दज आर
स्मॉल स्पैनिश बिग काफी बड़ा है यह वाला
बिग वाला तो शायद काफी बड़ा है वर्डलिस्ट
ये या इट्स ह्यूज इट्स ह्यूज सो हम तो
छोटा ही करेंगे डायरेक्टरी बट डायरेक्टरी
बस्टर का यूज कर लेंगे कोई सा भी यूज कर
लेंगे चलो ना एक बार देख लेते हैं ठीक है
तो हम यहां पर करते हैं यूएसआर शेयर
वर्डलिस्ट एंड इसमें देख लेते कौन सा यूज
करना है हमें वी विल गो विथ
द एस र बी वी आर गोइंग टू यूज डीआई आर बी
डीर बस्टर देन हम इसके अंदर यूज कर लेते
हैं डायरेक्टरी
लिस्ट 1.0
डायरेक्टरी डायरेक्टरी
लिस्ट चलिए यहां पर करते हैं डायरेक्टरी
एंड यहां पर कर लेते हैं लिस्ट एंड 1.0
वाली हम डायरेक्टरी जो है है वो जो हमारे
वर्ड लिस्ट है उसको हम यूज़ कर लेते हैं
इस तरीके से हम वर्ड लिस्ट प्रोवाइड कर
देते हैं उसके बाद उसके बाद आप अलग-अलग
ऑप्शंस इसमें प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो डिफरेंट
काइंड ऑफ ऑप्शंस यू कैन अ प्रोवाइड यू कैन
यूज या ठीक है जैसे मुझे चाहिए एक
पर्टिकुलर स्टेटस कोड्स वाले चाहिए जैसे
मुझे 200 स्टेटस कोर्स वाले ओनली फिल्टर
आउट करने हैं ओनली 200 स्टेटस कोर्स वाले
ठीक है तो मैं क्या करूंगा 200 स्टेटस
कोर्स वाले ही फाइंड करने की कोशिश करूंगा
तो हान यहां एमसी एक नाम का कीवर्ड है ऊपर
जाइए मैचिंग जो आपका यहां पे देखिए यहां
पे मैच कर ने का एक कोड है यहां पे अ ए
हान m एंड सी मैच एसटीटीपी स्टेटस कोड
मैचिंग कोड जो है आपको वो देना है तो चलिए
मैं मैचिंग कोड 200 दे देता हूं एंड
दैट्ची भी यूज़ कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं डबल
फ यूज़ कर लो व्हाट एवर आप कोई सा भी टूल
यूज़ कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है आप
डब् फज यूज कर लो आप डिजायर सर्च यूज कर
लो आप कोई सा भी जो आपकी मर्जी वो आप यूज
कर लो ठीक है तो यहां पे कुछ आपको एरस
वगैरह प्रोवाइड एरस की यहां पे आ रही है
आपकी कोई बात नहीं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोई
चलने दीजिए बट इस तरीके से आप रिजल्ट्स
फाइंड आउट कर लेंगे अब यहां पे देखो मैं
यहां पे इसको रोक रहा हूं बिकॉज़ ये काफी
टाइम ले सकता है यहां पे आप लोकल मशीन से
कर रहे हो फजिंग कर रहे हो जब आप लोकल
मशीन से फजिंग करते हो आपकी स्पीड थोड़ी
स्लो होती ही होती है ज्यादा फास्ट आपका
स्पीड नहीं होगा थोड़ा टाइम देना पड़ेगा
देन यू विल गेट टू द गेट द रिजल्ट्स ऑल द
रिजल्ट्स ओके बट जब आप वीपीएस वगैरह का
यूज़ करते हो क्लाउड में आप कोई मशीन यूज़
कर रहे हो दैट विल बी कंपैरेटिव वेरी वेरी
फास्ट आपको रिजल्ट बहुत फास्ट मिलेंगे एंड
आपके टाइम को बचाएंगे और आपके रिजल्ट्स
ज्यादा अच्छे आपको प्रोवाइड करेंगे ज्यादा
जल्दी मिलेंगे आपके चांसेस ज्यादा होंगे
एक वैलिड वल्नरेबल फाइंड करने का ठीक है
यह बात हमेशा ध्यान में रखिएगा यह मैंने
आपको आपको पहले भी बताया हुआ है
ओके
चलिए
ओके चलिए अब यहां पे आ गए अब यहां पे हमें
तो यह चीज मिल गई दो हमें यहां पे
रिजल्ट्स मिल गए हमें दो हमारे जो भी हमरे
रिजल्ट्स है इसके अकॉर्डिंग मिल गए हमारे
जो भी फिल्टर्स है उसके अकॉर्डिंग अब
फिल्टर्स में बहुत सारे और फिल्टर्स मिलते
हैं भैया आप यहां पे देखो बिटकॉइन से
रिलेटेड फिल्टर्स है यहां पे कुछ
रिस्ट्रिक्टेड जो है यह सिर्फ और सिर्फ
हायर प्लांस के लिए है टैग एंड वल वाला
इससे आप पर्टिकुलर वनबिल सीवी की डिटेल्स
फाइंड कर सकते हो यह भी काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
है जैसे पर्टिकुलर सीवी की डिटेल्स आपको
चाहिए ना तो आप यह वाला टैग व ये करके और
पर्टिकुलर सीवी का आप सीवी नंबर लिख दीजिए
यहां पे पूरा सीवी एंड आपको उससे रिलेटेड
डिटेल्स मिल जाएंगी अभी मैं सर्च करूंगा
ये नहीं ओपन होगा क्योंकि मेरा प्लान वो
नहीं है मेरा मेंबरशिप वाला प्लान है हायर
प्लान में ये ओपन होगा तो पर्टिकुलर सीवी
से रिलेटेड डिटेल्स या जो भी सीवी से
अफेक्टेड इस पर्टिकुलर सीवी से जो
इफेक्टेड वेबसाइट्स या सर्विसेस है ना वो
सारी आपके लिस्ट होके आ जाएंगी तो ये सडन
का पावर है सडन की पावर ये है इस तरीके से
सडन काम करता है अब मान लो अब देखो हां
सडन को आप क्या कर सकते हो एक चीज और मैं
बता देता हूं सडन को को आप अपने टर्मिनल
में भी यूज कर सकते हो काली में इंस्टॉल
कर सकते हो भैया यह कैसे होगा तो आप सडन
के डेवलपर वाले सेक्शन प आ
जाइएगा यहां पे
आइएगा नीचे आइएगा तो यहां पे आपको दिखेगा
कमांड लाइन फ्रेंडली द सडन कमांड लाइन
इंटरफेस एक्सपोज मोस्ट ऑफ द एपीआई इन अ
यूजर फ्रेंडली वे सो यू कैन एक्सेस द
शोडाउन डेटाबेस विदाउट नीडिंग टू राइट योर
ओन स्क्रिप्ट्स तो आप इसका इंस्टॉल द सीआई
प जाइएगा तो यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगा कैसे
इंस्टॉल करना है बस पिप इंस्टॉल चलाना है
पिप लाइ हो जाएगी या h u वाला नहीं भी
करेंगे तो यूजर आपका बन जाएगा वैसे ही से
बट नहीं भी करेंगे तो नॉर्मली आपके
पर्टिकुलर करंट यूजर में ही आपका ये यूज़
कर पाएंगे तो आपको क्या करना है सिंपल
बहुत इजी है यार शन को अगर आपको काली में
इंस्टॉल करनी है कमांड लाइन यूज़ करना है
वैसे मैं आपको बोलूंगा आप इसका जीआई यूज़
कीजिए ज्यादा बेटर है तो आप यहां पे
पिप इंस्टॉल शोडाउन कीजिए और एंटर कीजिए
एंड इट विल इंस्टॉल शान इन योर सिस्टम ठीक
है हो गया इंस्टॉल अब यहां शन को एक्सेस
कीजिए शान लिखिए एंड एंटर कीजिए आप इसकी
हेल्प फाइल आपकी खुल जाएगी अब आप इसको
इसके अकॉर्डिंग यूज़ कर सकते हैं यहां पे
आपको एक एपीआई की सेट करनी पड़ेगी शान की
अब देखो बहुत लोगों को एपीआई की सेट करने
नहीं आता कई सारे जब तुम टूल आगे आगे जब
तुम अभी बक बाउंटीज जो हमारी कोर्स चल रही
है तो आगे जो सेशंस होंगे उसमें कई ऐसे
टूल्स होंगे सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन के या और
भी बहुत सारे टूल्स होंगे जहां आपको शान
की या वायरस टोटल की जम आई की सेंसेस की
अलग-अलग तरह के सर्विसेस की एपीआई कीज
आपको कंफिल करनी पड़ेगी उनके जो एपीआई की
कॉन्फिन का जो भी फाइल है जहां पे एपीआई
की कंफिल करने का उन्होंने दे रखा है
इंस्ट्रक्ट कर रखा है वहां पे एपीआई कीज
डालनी पड़ती है अब वो एपीआई कीज कहां से
आएगी वो भी मैं आपको बता देता हूं बहुत
लोगों को नहीं पता होता है अब जैसे शान
इसको अगर आपको चलाना है तो आपको एपीआई की
कैसे डालना है आपको कमांड टाइप करनी है
सडन एंड देन करना है इट इट ये वाली इट और
उसके बाद आपको इसकी आईपीआई की डालनी है
मुझे कैसे पता चल रहा है मुझे कोई मैं कोई
भगवान नहीं हूं भाई कि मुझे ऐसे ही पता चल
जाएगा मुझे यहां से ही पता चल रहा है कि
शन इट एंड योर एपीआई की अब ये एपीआई की
आपकी कहां मिलेगी भैया तो आपका जो अकाउंट
है शान का आप इस वाले अकाउंट पर
जाइएगा अकाउंट प जाएंगे तो यहां पर आपको
एपीआई की लिखा रहेगा इसको शो प क्लिक
कीजिएगा आपकी एपीआई की शो हो जाएगी बस उसी
को कॉपी मारिए एंड यहां पे आप आके इसको
पेस्ट कीजिएगा एंड एंटर कीजिएगा आपका शान
कंफिल हो जाएगा एंड देन यू कैन स्टार्ट
यूजिंग द सडन कमांड जैसे उसके बाद अगर
आपको यूज करना है किसी पर्टिकुलर आईपी
एड्रेस की डिटेल चाहिए या कुछ भी डिटेल
चाहिए मान लो मुझे सडन एंड मुझे चाहिए अब
क्या है जैसे होस्ट ये देखो होस्ट ठीक है
या देर इज डोमेन है ना तो मान लो होस्ट है
मान लो ये होस्ट है मुझे एक पर्टिकुलर
आईपी के लिए डिटेल्स चाहिए तो मैंने होस्ट
डाला और उसके बाद एक आईपी एड्रेस डालनी है
तो चलो भैया मैं एक आईपी एड्रेस डाल देता
हूं तो यहां पर पिंग करता हूं
फड कॉ को सो यह आईपी सि दे रहा है क्या
ओके न 4 लगा देते
हैं ओके सो वी गट द आईपी अब हमें इस होस्ट
से रिलेटेड एक डिटेल्स चाहिए चलिए कॉपी
किया हमने इसको एंड यहां पर
हमने पेस्ट किया और एंटर किया अब हम जब
जैसे ही एंटर करेंगे हमें इस होस्ट से
रिलेटेड जो भी डिटेल्स है ना शन का जो
सीएल आई आपको प्रोवाइड कर देगा जैसे होस्ट
नेम्स क्या है ये होस्ट नेम्स आपको यहां
पे दिख गए ठीक है ये जो होस्ट नेम्स इसके
आ रहे हैं ये आ गए सिटी कोलकाता कंट्री
इंडिया ऑर्गेनाइजेशन मेटा प्लेटफॉर्म्स
आयरलैंड लिमिटेड एंड अपडेटेड जो भी है
नंबर ऑफ ओपन पोर्ट्स यहां पे आपको दिख रहे
हैं 80n 443 ठीक है तो सिंपल सा ये फंडा
है भैया सिंपल सा आपको ये मिल गया कोलकाता
इंडिया इसलिए क्योंकि ये जो सर्वर की
डिटेल्स ये जो आईपी आपको दिख रही है अभी
जो
ये आईपी हमारे इंडिया की ही
कि नहीं पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट जैसे हमने देखा
था ना बहुत सारे हनी पोट्स आए थे हमें
मिले हुए थे उसके लिए आप चेक आउट कर सकते
हो
जैसे
सॉरी चलिए यहां चल देते हैं एंड लेट्स गो
टू सोडा यहां चल देते हैं एंड यहां पे
हमने देखा था
वेबकैम वेब कम पे हमने जब एंटर किया था तो
हमें बहुत सारे हनी पॉट्स मिले थे देखो
जैसे कि यह देखो ये हनी पॉट एक मिला हुआ
था ये हनी पॉट एक ये एक हनी पॉट मिली थी
ये एक हनी पॉट मिली थी तो एक ये आईपी हमें
मि है तो हम इस आईपी को कॉपी करके यहां पे
हनी पट ये है कि नहीं है इसका चेक आउट कर
सकते हैं चलिए एक बार देख लेते हैं ओके
कहां गया ये ठीक है तो क्या कर सकते हैं
हम यहां पे कीवर्ड डाल सकते हैं हनी स्कोर
वाला यूज कर वी कैन यूज दिस ठीक है सो
लेट्स शो डन ए लेट्स शो डाउन देन हनी हनी
स्कोर एंड जो आईपी आपको जिस पे हनी पॉट
चेक करना है अ उसकी डिटेल्स डाल दीजिएगा
ये आपको बताएगा अनेबल टू कैलकुलेट हनी
स्कोर ठीक है अभी हनी स्कोर कैलकुलेट नहीं
कर पा रहा बट इस तरीके से आप चेक आउट कर
सकते हैं हालांकि श डान ग्राफिकली आपको सब
कुछ शो कर देता है तो आपको इसकी जरूरत
वैसे कुछ खास नहीं पड़ने वाली है ठीक है
नहीं पड़ने वाली
ओके क्या बोल रहे हैं यह स्नाइपर एक्स
वाटी अ व्हाट इज व्हाट हैपन स्नाइपर एकटी
स्नाइपर आपको अगर आप फॉरेन से अगर आपको
फ्री वाले में आना है तो आप क्रेडिट कार्ड
अपना लोकल यूज कर सकते हैं वहां से आप आप
उसमें इनरोल कर सकते हैं ठीक
है आएंगे आएंगे आएंगे उसपे भी आएंगे
वैंपायर भाई उसपे भी आएंगे टेंशन नहीं
लेने का उसपे भी आएंगे बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज है वो वो तो मैं डिटेल में डील करूंगा
ठीक है पहले इधर देख लीजिए आप देखिए डेली
आप हर एक सेशन को लाइव अटेंड करो अच्छा
मुझे एक बात बताओ मुझे आपसे
एक सर यह सब जो इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर किया है
उसे मैनेज कैसे करें इतनी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
भी कंफ्यूज
होगा ठीक है देखो कंफ्यूजन कुछ नहीं वायरस
टोटल के सेटिंग में जाओ एपीआई की मिल
जाएगी कंफ्यूजन कुछ नहीं है एक आराम से
कोई भी एक स्प्रेडशीट या नोटबुक ऑनलाइन
नोटबुक्स जो होते हैं उसको बनाओ उसको
तैयार करो उसको रेडी रखो एंड उसी में सारा
कुछ नोट करो उसमें या एक्सेल शीट बना लो
या व्हाट एवर यू वांट यू कैन मेक एंड यू
कैन जस्ट यूज दैट थिंग ठीक है आप उसको यूज
कीजिए एंड उसी का उसी से आप सारी चीजें जो
है वो मॉनिटर भी कर सकते हैं एंड सारी
चीजें आप उसके अकॉर्डिंग कीजिएगा तो आप
एकदम से लाइन बाय लाइन जो चीजें है वो
करके रखिएगा ठीक है तो आपको ज्यादा मजा
आएगा आपको मैनेज करने में ज्यादा मजा आएगा
सर आई कैन सर कैन आई सेंड यू सुपर चैट सो
यू एबल टू एबल माय फ्री ो नहीं नहीं मैं
डायरेक्ट एक्सेस आपको नहीं दे पाऊंगा मेरे
साइड से भी व वो वो मेरे पास वो अथॉरिटी
नहीं है कि आपको डायरेक्टली एक्सेस दिलवा
पाऊ ठीक है आपको वो करके नरोल करके ही आना
पड़ेगा हां कर सकते हो कर सकते हो बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल यू कैन
यूज चेरी टेरी सब यूज कर लो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है चलिए तो यह तो एक चीज हो गई आपके
पास भैया आपको सडन का मैंने सील आई
इंस्टॉलेशन भी बता दिया अब क्या क्या
दिक्कत है भाई बताइए
नोशन का यूज कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं नोशन
यूज कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है चलो मैं कुछ
चैट्स देख लेता हूं यहां
पे नोशन यूज कर लो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है ओके आई विल से मैं रिकमेंड करूंगा आपको
कि यूज द शोडाउन जीय आई प्लीज आपको मैं
रिकमेंड करूंगा सील आई के ऊपर ज्यादा मत
जाओ आपको दिक्कत आएगी अभी ठीक है ना अभी
आपको दिक्कत आएगी क्यों दिक्कत करना ना
आपको बग फाइंड करने हैं आपको हंट करना है
कि दिक्कत करनी है बस यह चीज बताओ इससे
मतलब नहीं होना चाहिए कि आपका अप्रोच किस
तरह का आपका अप्रोच है मतलब सीआ यूज़ कर
रहे हो कि जीआई यूज कर नहीं मुझे इससे
मतलब होना चाहिए कि रिजल्ट मुझे क्या मिल
रहा है और कितनी फास्ट मिल रही है बस
दैट्ची जो हंटर्स है बाकी जो एथिकल हैकर्स
है जो रिसर्चस हैं उनसे पहले रिपोर्ट करें
उस पर्टिकुलर वलने बिलिटी को समझ में आ
गया अब देखो जैसे मैं एक चीज बताता हूं
देखो जैसे एक चीज और यहां पे देखते हैं अ
जैसे व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू
डू एसएसएल वाली जो हमारी थी
[संगीत]
अ चलो यह हमने डाला था सीए facebook.com
वाली हमें रिजल्ट्स मिले थे हमने फिर से
इसको सर्च किया वी आर गोइंग टू सर्च दिस
अगेन एंड हमें 5632 यहां पर रिजल्ट्स हमें
मिले थे ठीक है ये रिजल्ट्स वी गॉट अब
मुझे एक पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल के एंड पॉइंट्स
चाहिए अगर तो यह भी आप इससे फाइंड करेंगे
इसके लिए आपको वेब आइ यूज करना पड़ेगा
जैसे मेरे पास एक कोई सब डोमेन निकालो
जैसे कोई भी सब डोमेन जैसे कि एक्टन
facebook.com ठीक है सिक्य facebook.com
गुड एक्न facebook.com नेक्स्ट पर क्लिक
करते हैं कोई और भी देख लेते हैं सब डोमेन
है क्या एक्सटर्न और सिक्योर के अलावा
सिक्योर
एक्सटर्न
सिक्योर ठीक है एक्सटर्न ओके सिर्फ यही आ
रहा है हमारे पास ठीक है तो हम कोई सा भीय
कर लेते हैं मान लो हम एक्सटर्न वाला जो
है ना यह वाला एक्सटर्न या सिक्योर दोनों
में से कोई एक यूज कर लेते हैं हम यहां पर
एक यूज करने वाले हैं वेब आर्काइव का एक
एपीआई वहां से हम कुछ फेच करने वाले हैं
जैसे देखो वेब आर्काइव का वेब आर्काइव का
एक सीडीएक्स एपीआई करके आता है सीडीएक्स
एपीआई ठीक है मैं इसको ओपन करता हूं इनका
इनकी वेबसाइट ओपन कर लेते हैं यहां पे
सीडीएक्स सव की जो एपीआई है आप इसको यूज
करके कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट डिटेल्स या फाइंड कर
सकते हो जैसे आप नीचे जाओगे इसको यूज करने
का आपको तरीका बताएगा जैसे यूआरएल मैच
स्कोप का यूज कर सकते हो यूआरएल मैचिंग
स्कोप के लिए यहां पे ठीक है यहां पर नीचे
आते हैं फिल्टरिंग हमें फिल्टरिंग वाला
यूज करना है फिल्टरिंग क्या हम यूज कर
सकते हैं कुछ फिल्टर वगैरह यूज करने के
लिए क्लैप्स वाला यूज कर सकते हैं तो चलो
इसमें से कोई सा भी एक जैसे हम यहां
पे यह वाला यूज करते हैं ठीक है एक हम
यह ये वाला यूज करते यूआरएल की वाली इसको
हमने यूज किया अब हम क्या करेंगे गाइस अह
वी आर गोइंग टू यूज़ दिस वन
url.com है ठीक है अह लेट्स प्रोवाइड इट
वयर इज़ द
facebook.com इसको यूज़ कर लो या तुम
एक्सटर्न वाला यूज़ कर लो कोई बात नहीं
चलो रए में हमने यह दे दिया स्यो
facebook.com एंड नाउ लेट्स प्रेस द एंटर
की इट विल ट्राई टू प्रोवाइड ऑल द एंड
पॉइंट्स जो भी यूआरएल एंड पॉइंट्स यूआरएल
है वो आपको यहां पे ये प्रोवाइड करेगा ये
वेब आर्काइव का जो एक तरह से जो सीडीएक्स
एपीआई है उससे आपको रिजल्ट्स ये फैच करके
मिलेंगे अब देखिए बहुत सारे रिजल्ट्स ये
बहुत बड़ा रिजल्ट है देखो ये तुम दिमाग
तुम्हारा खराब हो जाएगा अब सबको एनालाइज
करना है भाई तुम्हें सब कुछ देखना है क्या
है क्या नहीं है सब कुछ देखना है ये देखो
ये देखो इतने रिजल्ट्स है और इस रिजल्ट की
खासियत यह है कि इट विल गिव यू द स्टेटस
कोड्स एज वेल तो मुझे अगर कोई 404 स्टेटस
कोड्स वाले रिजल्ट्स चाहिए तो मैं कंट्रोल
f करूंगा 404 करूंगा तो मुझे मिलेंगे 1000
से भी ज्यादा मैचेस तो अब जो 404 वाले हैं
ये सारे ये देखो सारे 404 वाले हैं जैसे
एडीबी ये वाला
यूआरएल ये 404 है मैं इसको अगर ओपन करूंगा
इट विल गिव मी द 404 देखो नॉट फाउंड बैक
टू
भाई हक्कर वाली
चलिए लेट्स गो टू सम अ चलिए यहां पे मैं
एंटर करता हूं थोड़ा फास्ट करता हूं यहां
पे कुछ और भी रिजल्ट्स पे चलते हैं यहां
पे वी आर गोइंग हियर देखो टेक्स्ट
एचटीएमएल एचटीएमएल बहुत सारे रिजल्ट्स
हमें मिल रहे हैं यहां पे 404 के यहां पे
हो सकता है इसमें कोई ऐसी आपको चीज मिल
जाए जो कोई एक सब डोमेन पे पर्टिकुलर जो
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग आपको रिजल्ट्स प्रोवाइड
कर दे 404 में ये भी हो सकता है आप 200 के
लिए कर लो 200 के लिए भी आप फिल्टर आउट कर
सक सकते हो तो 200 वाले जो स्टेटस कोड्स
हैं वो सारे आपको यहां पे 200 स्टेटस
कोड्स वाले मिल जाएंगे जो भी यूआरएल है वो
मिल जाएंगे जैसे एक य य यूआरएल जो है ये
भी मिला मुझे एक ये यूआरएल है यह भी मुझे
मिल रहा है सो 200 वाले स्टेटस कोर्स वाले
यूआरएल जैसे ये कौन सी यूआरएल है भाई अ
वयर इज इट वेर इट इज कहां गई भाई यह
यूआरएल छोटा है ना यार लंबी यूआरएल है
थोड़ी सी लंबी यूआरएल है मतलब ये यूआरएल
आपको 200 वाले यूआरएल मिल रहे हैं सारे जो
भी स्टेटस कोड्स है उसके अकॉर्डिंग भी आप
कर सकते हैं मुझे मान लो 403 वाले चाहिए
तो 403 वाले भी जो भी स्टेटस कोड्स के अगर
कुछ यहां पे इनको मिले होते हैं कुछ भी
यहां पे स्टेटस कोर्स वाले अगर आपको
मिलेंगे तो ये आपको यहां पे दे देंगे उसके
अकॉर्डिंग अब मुझे चाहिए अब मैं क्या करता
हूं ना मैं एक चीज करता हूं मैं यहां करता
हूं बैकअप यह कीवर्ड सर्च करता हूं कुछ है
क्या यहां पे यह देखो कुछ देयर इज समथिंग
ओके ओ व्हाट दिस यूआरएल डॉक्स ओके ये
डॉक्यूमेंट डॉक्स है ये ये डॉक यूआरएल है
हालांकि कोई अ ये कोई ऐसी कोई सेंसिटिव
चीज नहीं होगी डॉक्यूमेंट होगी मतलब
बेसिकली आप इसको पढ़ सकते हैं इसको पढ़ के
आपको पढ़ने वाली चीज है ये कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है बट बैकअप के लिए आप सर्च कर सकते
हैं कोई बैकअप फाइल या कुछ ऐसा कुछ मिल
जाए इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ मिल जाए तो कितना मजा
आ जाए बट यहां पे ज्यादा नहीं है छह ही है
ओनली तो ज्यादा कुछ आपको यहां पे मिलेगा
नहीं या डॉट जिप ऐसे करके आप सर्च कर सकते
हैं बट यहां पे कुछ नहीं है डॉट जड कुछ
नहीं है यहां पे डॉटी
टी जी जड नहीं कुछ भी नहीं मिल रहा हमें
तो ऐसा कुछ हमें आप पर्टिकुलर किसी
पर्टिकुलर एक्सटेंशन के लिए पर्टिकुलर
यूआरएल के लिए आप यहां पर सर्च आउट कर
सकते हैं या आप चाहिए आपको एपीआई से
रिलेटेड कुछ मैचिंग कुछ मिले तो आपको
एपीआई से रिलेटेड मिल जाएगा जैसे आप देखो
यहां
पे दिस वन ग्राफ कल एंड दिस वन व्हाट इज
दिस एटीपीए सेक्यर फ एजेक्स पेमेंट टोकन
प्रॉक्सी ग्राफ कल एंड दिस वन दिस यूआरएल
वी गॉट सम यूआरएल हियर लेट्स प्रेस द एंटर
की एंड व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू गेट ओके ओके
दिस इज इंटरेस्टिंग अ इस पे देखते हैं बाद
में इसमें मैं देखूंगा कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
यूआरएल भी आपको मिल रहे हैं जैसे एपीआई से
रिलेटेड आपको कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग यूआरएल भी
यहां पे मिल जाएंगे यहां पे 32 परमानेंट अ
मूव्ड आपका मूव हो चुका है गेटवे इस तरीके
से यू कैन फाइंड आउट अब मुझे यहां पे
पासवर्ड कुछ मिलेगा क्या पासवर्ड से
रिलेटेड कुछ नहीं मिला मुझे एडमिन से
रिलेटेड कुछ मिल रहा है क्या कुछ नहीं
मिला यूजर से रिलेटेड कुछ मिल रहा है क्या
अ यस वी गॉट समथिंग बहुत सारी चीजें हैं
यूजर से रिलेटेड तो मिल जाएंगी आपको यहां
पे बहुत सारी चीजें आईपी एंड ऑल आईपी से
रिलेटेड कुछ अगर मिलता है तो यू कैन जस्ट
सर्च इट एंड फाइंड आउट ठीक है आप इस तरह
की चीजें कर सकते हैं या पीएचपी आकर आपको
कोई पर्टिकुलर पीएचपी से रिलेटेड यूआरएल
चाहिए कुछ ऐसा चाहिए तो आप ये चीज देख
सकते हैं जैसे ये देखो मुझे एक यूआरएल ये
मिली लेट्स ट्राई टू फाइंड आउट एंड लेट्स
सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग ऑन दिस सो या नथिंग
हियर कुछ भी नहीं है तो ज आप ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हो यू कैन ट्राई आउट राइट ओके
चलिए तो यह आपको समझ में आ गया इस तरीके
से यू कैन गेट द डिटेल्स यू कैन गेट
डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ रिजल्ट्स यू कैन जस्ट आप
इस पर फिर फदर एक्शन ले सकते हो एंड यह वे
बैक का जो आपका यह जो यूआरएल है मैं आपको
सेंड कर देता हूं चैट में चैट में आप सबके
लिए आई एम सेंडिंग ले लीजिए चैट में ये
लीजिए कंट्रोल बी
पेंटर चलिए मैंने चैट में भेज दिया है आई
हैव सेंट इन द चैट ठीक है चैट में मैंने
सेंड कर दिया है ओके एंड मुझे जस्ट लेट मी
सी बताइए बताइए बताइए मैं देख रहा हूं
बताइए बताइए
बताइए
बताइए ठीक
है अ ओके हाउ डू यू सर एक्सेस ब्राउजर
कंसोल क्या
कंसोल सर आई एम नॉट फ्रॉम इंडिया हाउ कैन
आई बाय ₹1 कोर्स ब्रदर गो टू द कोर्स एंड
ट्राई टू पे वाया क्रेडिट कार्ड ऑफ योर ओन
कंट्री इंटरनेशनल क्रेडिट कार्ड इज
एक्सेप्टेड देयर ओनली
क्रेडिट ठीक है ओके अच्छा मुझे ये ये सडन
की पावर है भाई ये सडन ये सडन का यूज हम
बहुत करने वाले हैं आने वाले टाइम में अब
टाइम प अगर तुम यह बोलोगे ना कि सर सडन
सडन क्या होता है क्या बताया आपने सडन के
बारे में तो फिर देख लेना भाई यह गलत बहुत
गलत चीज हो जाएगी तो ये
facebook.com य एसएल सर्च सब्जेक्ट स
facebook.com मिल गया मुझे अब मान लो मुझे
सिर्फ फ अब आप इसको ना ऐसे भी कर सकते हो
होस्ट
नेम होस्ट नेम ऐसे सर्च किया एंटर किया
लेट्स सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग हमें अब मिला क्या
12688 रिजल्ट्स मिले होस्ट नेम पे होस्ट
नेम पे मतलब आप सिर्फ होस्ट नेम के लिए
यानी
[संगीत]
वेलकम टू द स्ट्रीम स्ट्रम ओके
टी आई टी एल ई टाइटल एंड यहां पर हमने दे
दिया फास्ट पैनल एंड अब हम इसकी रिजल्ट्स
को एनालाइज करते हैं भैया कि इससे हमें
क्या रिजल्ट्स मिलते हैं दो ही मिले हैं
हमें फास्ट पैनल के एंड इसका कॉमन नेम
पार्किंग है ऑर्गनाइजेशन फास्ट पैनल है
नॉट रिलेटेड
टू फ सम हाउ सम हाउ चलो ठीक है इसको देखते
क्या है
यह सेप्ट है इक्सड एटी य सीधा फास्ट पैनल
का इक्सड एटीए है कुछ है नहीं चलिए कोई
बात नहीं कोई टेंशन नहीं लेनी है यह भी
सेम सिमिलर चीज है तो कुछ मतलब कुछ तो
मिला है यार कुछ तो मिलता ही है कुछ ऐसे
करोगे तो कुछ ना कुछ मिलेगा बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज भी मिल सकती है तुम्हे तो
यही तो टाइम देना होता है भाई टाइम नहीं
दोगे तो कैसे
होगा कौन सी लिंक नहीं ओपन हो रही है भाई
लिंक हां वो भी बताता हूं सडन का फ्री
अल्टरनेटिव फ्री अल्टरनेटिव नहीं है मतलब
सडन की तरह ही है फ्री तो कुछ नहीं मिलेगा
भाई ऐसा कोई सर्विस आपको बिल्कुल फ्री तो
नहीं मिलने जा रहा है एकदम से आप याद
रखिए
एरर 404 नॉट फाउंड यह काफी अच्छी चीज हो
सकती है इसमें आपको मिल सकता है बहुत सारी
चीजें 3cx फोन सिस्टम मैनेजमेंट कंसोल
आपको यह मिल जाएगा यह भी अच्छी चीज हो
सकती है सो वी कैन ट्राई टू फाइंड आउट अभी
मैं सडन के अलावा भी एक चीज बताऊंगा बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज बताऊंगा टेंशन मत लो
तो यहां पर हमने इसको सर्च किया तीन
रिजल्ट्स है इसके लेट्स सी एक यह कंसोल
मैनेजमेंट का है चलो भैया देखते हैं क्या
है
यह आहा यह क्या
है यह कोई एक यूआरएल देखो एक यूआरएल जहां
पे लॉगिन पैनल है कोई एक मैनेजमेंट कंसोल
है 3cx मैनेजमेंट कंसोल ये लॉगिन पैनल
मिला मुझे यूजर नेम और एक्सटेंशन नंबर
एडमिन ओबवियसली डिफॉल्ट तो नहीं होगा बट
स्टिल लेट्स गिव इट अ ट्राई एडमिन लेट्स
लॉग इन एंड इनकरेक्ट एडमिन 1 23 इनकरेक्ट
यहां अलग-अलग तरह के एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शंस
वगैरह य यूज़ कर सकते हैं ये भी ट्राई मार
सकते हैं स्कल इंजेक्शन के भी ट्राई कर
सकते हैं डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स वी कैन
ट्राई फॉर ब्रूट फोर्सिंग एंड ऑल ये सारी
चीजें हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं तो उसके
लिए कोई टेंशन ले लेनी है वो आपको ट्राई
करना है यही तो बग बांटी है यार बग बांटी
का यही तो गेम है भाई बिना इसके फिर तो
क्या ही है
राइट वेब आर्काइव वाला नहीं काम कर रहा
बताइए भाई सेंसेस इज आल्सो गुड वेब
आर्काइव वाला काम नहीं कर रहा है एंड यही
तो बात है कि आप लोग ध्यान नहीं देते हैं
आपने देखा नहीं मैंने वेब आर्काइव के
यूआरएल जब फेच कर रहा था है तो मैं कैसे
फेच कर रहा था मैं क्या यूज क्या तरीके से
कर रहा था डायरेक्ट आप यूआरएल खोजो ग कैसे
मिलेगा भाई डायरेक्ट तुम यूआरएल यहां पे
पेस्ट कर यहां पे जो मैंने तुम्हें दिया
है यूआरएल वही खोलोगे थोड़ी ना यह भैया
वेब आर्काइव वाले में तुम्हें यहां पे यह
यूआरएल इ टू आइ . है इसके जगह पे तुम्हें
वो वाली यूआरएल देनी है जिसके बारे में
जिसके एंड पॉइंट्स तुम्हें चाहिए भाई जैसे
सिक्योर ड facebook.com ये दिया हमने अब
इससे रिलेटेड जो भी डिटेल्स है वो आएंगे
नहीं मिल रहा हमें ठीक ठीक है भैया हम
एक्सटर्न पे चलते हैं एक्सटर्न
facebook.com वी डिड नॉट गेट हमें यहां पे
वाइल्ड कार्ड यूज करना है यानी कि
[संगीत]
stn.to कुछ होगा नहीं बट यहां पर मुझे कुछ
मिली है रोटस एकटी कीय 200 है यह यह कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग हो सकता है यहां तो कुछ ना
कुछ तो है ओ हो हो हो हो हो हो 10n
facebook.com
robot.com मींस इज प्रोब अनलेस यू हैव
एक्सप्रेस रिटेन परमिशन फ्रॉम फ एंड मे
ओनली बी कंड लिमिटेड पर्पस कंटेंट इन
स्टेट परमिशन ओके मुझे यहां कुछ तो मिला
है गाइस एंड वी विल ट्राई टू वी विल ट्राई
टू गेट वी विल ट्राई टू
डू समथिंग कुछ तो भाई मिला है अभी देख
देखते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग व्ट इ
देर इन फोट पीएपी स्
फट पीएपी कुछ है क्या
् देर इ
नथिंग कोई बात नहीं हम कुछ और भी
देखेंगे लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक
यूजर एजेंट इ दिस यूजर एजेंट एल ब यूजर
एेंट स्पाइडर यूजर एजेंट कौन सा है बिंग
बट यूजर डिस्ड बट यूज
[संगीत]
google.cin इन पर्टिकुलर लोकेशंस को क्रॉल
ना करे जैसे
सकते जहां कुछ ऐसी चीज रखी हुई है जो फ
नहीं चाहती है कि
कोई बात नहीं लॉगइन कर ले क्या कुछ फसबुक
लॉगइन है क्या अपना यहां पर आई थंक इ साइड
में लॉगइन होगा मेरा फेसबुक
शायद साइड में लगन है ना आई ओके या या या
या या या या
या ओके सो यहां पर लॉगिन तो है सो लेट्स
ट्राई टू
हंट ले ा टू ओपन दिस वन कांटेक्ट इंपोर्टर
यह हम इस वाले पे ट्राई करते
हैं इस वाले पे लेट्स ट्राई दिस यर ो एकटी
प आते हैं एंड यहां पे यहां पे कुछ ट्राई
करते हैं कुछ और भी यहां पे स् पड पीएपी
व्ट इ स् पड पीए स् पड पीए पड पीप लेट्स
ट्र कुछ है क्या
नहीं नथिंग यार भाई इसमें टाइम देना कुछ
ना कुछ तो तुम्हें मिल भी सकता है कोई
टेंशन लेने वाली बात नहीं है बहुत कुछ मिल
सकता है कांटेक्ट इंपोर्टर यह देखते हैं
यह क्या
कुछ ओके लेट्स ट्राई टू फाइंड व्ट्स दिस
कांटेक्ट
इंपोर्टर देख कुछ ना कुछ तो मिलेगा
भाई कंटेंट इज नॉट अवेलेबल एट द मोमेंट
मतलब ठीक है यह अवेलेबल नहीं है इट्स फाइन
ककल मूमेंट मोमेंट अंडरस्कोर
ए यह वाली ट्राई तो करेंगे भैया होस्ट
10 होस्ट 10 ल ट्राई
दिस होस्ट 10 कहां गई भैया होस्ट 10 होस्ट
10 यह रही होस्ट 10 यह रही स्लस एंड
मोमेंट्स ऐप लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
देयर अ नॉट अवेलेबल मतलब ठीक है ये
अवेलेबल नहीं है कोई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
कोई बात नहीं है भाई कोई टेंशन नहीं है
मतलब आपको यहां पे robots.txt मिली अब
robot.txt का मतलब यही होता है जो मैंने
आपको समझा दिया कि एक ऐसी लोकेशन होती है
एक फाइल होती है जो जिसके अंदर जब आप ये
डिस अलाउ वाली ये वाली जब एंट्री करते हो
डिस अलाउ इसका मतलब ये होता है कि इसको
क्रॉल करने से रोकना है इसको क्रॉल नहीं
करना है सर्च इंजंस को इस पर्टिकुलर सर्च
इंजन को एंड यह आपको आपसे छिपाने के लिए
किया जाता है ताकि जनरली अवेलेबल ना हो
पब्लिक के लिए बट हम उसको डायरेक्टली
विजिट करके ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं समथिंग
समथिंग एंड समथिंग राइट यह चीज हम कर सकते
हैं या इट विल इट
विल हां हां जी भाई डिस अलाउ वाले को ही
तो करना एक्सेस मजा आ रहा है ना डिसला
वाले को ही तो एक्सेस करना है भैया है ना
इसको ही तो एक्सेस करना है राइट चलिए तो
यह आपको समझ में आ गई होगी इस तरीके से आप
शान को यूज कर रहे हैं वो यूज करेंगे इस
तरीके से यू कैन यूज दिस शोडाउन अब चलिए
शान को
आप तो हमें यहां पे कुछ कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
चीजें तो मिलनी शुरू हो हो चुकी है यहां
पे हम फिल्टर आउट फिल्टर वगैरह लगा सकते
हैं फिल्टर लगा के भी हम ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं यहां पे एंड हमने यहां पे देखा
मैं बैक कर लेता हूं यहां पे यहां पर
टाइटल में और भी चीजें हैं जैसे हमने तो
ये 3cx वाला देखा था चलो अच्छी बात है थ्र
एरर थ ये 404 वाली भी है तो एक बार 404
वाली देखते हैं कोई ऐसा कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
तो नहीं मिल जाएगा ना
भाई लेट्स ट्राई टू फाइंड 404 में
रिजल्ट्स जो भी आपको आ रहे हैं चलिए देखते
हैं 14 रिजल्ट्स है ना 4 16 रिजल्ट्स है
16 रिजल्ट आया हमें लेट्स सी व्ट इज देयर
google.com है सच में क्या है देखते हैं
एक्सेप्ट रिस्क एंड कंटिन्यू इतना रिस्क
लेंगे ओके नॉट अवेलेबल अच्छी बात है व्हाट
इज
दिस
अ
नथिंग व्हाट इज दिस दिस सारे 404 वाले जो
हैं इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं टू सी व्हाट वी
आर गेटिंग ऑन देयर ये रहा तो यहां एडवांस
करते हैं यहां एक्सेप्ट एंड कंटिन्यू
लेट्स सी इ समथिंग इंटरेस्टिंग देयर कुछ
नहीं है यहां भी देख लेते हैं यहां कुछ है
क्या कुछ भी नहीं है यहां कुछ भी नहीं है
एंड यहां देख लेते हैं एंड यहां कुछ भी
नहीं है अ नथिंग देयर यहां देख लेते हैं
एडवांस एंड इज देयर इन समथिंग नथिंग चलिए
यहां कुछ भी कुछ खास है नहीं यहां पे कुछ
हमें कुछ खास मिला नहीं बट मिला नहीं इसका
मतलब यह नहीं कि मिलेगा भी नहीं और इसका
मतलब यह नहीं कि नहीं आपको कुछ नहीं मिल
पा रहा भैया आपको एक्सप्लोर करते रहना है
बग बाउंट यही होती है अगर आप बग बाउंट में
हार मान जाएंगे बग बाउंटीज जाएंगे बग
बाउंट में पेशेंस लूज कर जाएंगे और बग
बाउंट में टाइम नहीं देंगे तो यकीन मानिए
यू आर नॉट गोइंग टू बिकम प्रो हंटर आप फिर
थोड़ा पीछे रह जाएंगे चलिए ये तो आपको समझ
में आ गया ये आपको यह बताइए अब तक जो भी
आपको बताया समझाया वो आपको समझ में आया ना
सबको ये मुझे बता दीजिए मैं एक बार चैट
देख लेता हूं पहले मैं एक बार इंटरेक्ट कर
लेता हूं आप लोगों से पहले जल्दी से लेट
मी नो सब कुछ समझ में आ गया और मैं तब तक
एक शेड्यूल भी कर लेता हूं देयर इज अ
शेड्यूल टू डू एक क्लास की शेड्यूल है
मेरी अ वो मैं शेड्यूल कर देता हूं जो
हमारी लाइव ट्रेनिंग चलती है ना अ उसकी
शेड्यूल करनी है सो लेट मी शेड्यूल दैट और
चैट भी तब तक मैं आपका पढ़ लूंगा तो चैट
चैट चैट चैट चैट यस सो चैट में ओके आपके
जो भी रिजल्ट है सॉरी जो भी आपके क्वेश्चन
है चैट में अभी बता दीजिए मैं चैट में
क्वेश्चन ले लेता हूं तब तक मैं इधर
शेड्यूल भी करता हूं आपके क्वेश्चन भी ले
लेता हूं ठीक है अभी एक और चीज हम देखने
वाले हैं बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग अभी क्लास खत्म
नहीं हुई है भाई एक बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग अभी
सडन का एक अल्टरनेटिव भी बताने वाला हूं
आपको ठीक है अल्टरनेटिव ऑफ शान वो जरूर
देखिएगा क्या है अल्टरनेटिव
ओके जल्दी बता दीजिए जल्दी से जल्दी जल्दी
चैट में कोई भी आपके सवाल हो पूछ लीजिए
प्लीज आस्क योर
क्वेश्चन
[संगीत]
ओके जल्दी पूछिए ओके शाउट आउट मोहम्मद
अहमद ताहिर जी भैया शट आउट दे दिया आपको
मैंने मोहम्मद अहमद ताहिर
जी
च इट्स थर्ड दिसंबर ना थर्ड दिसंबर थड दिस
नहीं नहीं थर्ड दिसंबर थोड़ी ना यार थड जन
है यार ड
जैन
24 मैं क्लास शेड्यूल कर रहा हूं तब तक आप
क्वेश्चंस अपने पूछ
लीजिए जो हमारी हैकिंग की लाइव ट्रेनिंग
चलती है डिप्लोमा सिक्स मंथ्स वाली उसकी
एक क्लास है वो शेड्यूल कर रहा हूं मैं
क्योंकि इसके बाद वही क्लास होनी है तो थड
जन 24 830 पीएम पे है ना
ओके ओके बता दीजिए जल्दी से ओपन वीपीएन
क्या ये शट देरिया भाई अब बारबार करोगे तो
दिक्कत है आपके कोई भी क्वेश्चन नहीं है
क्या आप लोगों के लाइक आपके कोई भी
क्वेश्चन नहीं है क्या गाइस आपके मोहम्मद
अहमद ताहिर आई हैव गिवन द शट आउट ऑलरेडी
प्लीज बड़ी डोंट
रिपीट
ओके सर हाउ टू यूज वीपीएस इन क्लाउड
फ्लेयर यूज क्या क्या बना क्या बता रहे हो
भाई क्या पूछ रहे हो यह हाउ टू यूज वीपीएस
इन क्लाउड फेयर यूज करने का वीडियो बना
दीजिए मतलब करना क्या चाहते हो यह तो बताओ
मुझे एटली व्ट यू वांट टू
डू
ओके
अच्छा
एपीआई वाला समझा दीजिए कौन सा एपीआई वाला
भाई एपीआई वाला बताया तो था यार
अभी अभी तो बताया एपीआई
वाला अभी मैं बताऊंगा ओस के लिए भी बहुत
सारी चीज बताऊंगा यार अभी तो अभी अभी तो
बहुत सारी चीज बाकी है भाई और भाई लाइक तो
आज बहुत कम है यार लाइक बहुत कम है यार सच
में सर बब शूट अगेन ओपन करने अगेन लाइसेंस
डालने पर पर रह रहा है अगेन वो मेथड यूज
करना पड़ रहा है कोई बात नहीं आप बारबार
यूज कर लीजिए कोई टेंशन नहीं है जब जब यूज
करना हो कर लीजिए चल तो जा रहा है ना
ट्राई हैक सब्सक्रिप्शन के बारे में आप
लोग टे ग्रा प आप लोगों ने मैसेज किया हुआ
था आप लोगों को रिवर्ट किया जाएगा टेंशन
नहीं लेना है ठीक
है बताएंगे बग बाउंट रिपोर्टिंग को भी
बताएंगे अच्छा मुझे बताओ यार 990 लोग लगभग
देख रहे हैं बट इसमें कुछ ही लोग हैं जो
मैसेज कर रहे हैं चैट में बाकी लोग कहां
है किस जगह पे है क्यों है और क्यों नहीं
है यहां बाकी लोग चैट में क्यों नहीं है
मुझे आप लोग एक सब एक बार सब अपने नाम बता
दो यार एक बार एवरीवन प्लीज टेल मी योर
नेम्स एवरीवन टेल मी द
नेम आप सभी लोग अपना नाम बताइए
जरा लेट्स
सी सभी लोग नाम बताइए एक बार सभी लोग
एवरीवन ओके आदित्य अंशु आप लोग नाम बताइए
मैं आप लोगों का नाम लेता हूं य आदित्य
अंशु जिष्णु सुनील परमार विशाल हिरेन
आदित्य पवन कुमार राहुल
कुशवाहा
अरुण अरुण गौरव
मयंक समा ता अक्षय अनिरुद्ध
समम अवी सुंदरम राहुल
देवांजलि यार राजीव अपना नाम रियल बताओ
आदित्य हंशराज
मार्या राजू अभय प्रताप अदिल राहुल ओके
पंकज
करण ओके
भूपेंद्र
हितेश
दिव्या राहुल ठीक है चलिए
सुरेंद्र सर आपका डिप्लोमा कोर्स कैसे
जवाइन करना है डिप्लोमा कोर्स जब आएगी
नेक्स्ट अनाउंसमेंट होगी तो आप जवाइन कर
लीजिएगा डिफ अकेडमी पे टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
ैनू पे सब पे आइए भूपेंद्र जोगी ठीक है सब
पे रहिए गोविंद
ओके ओके चलिए रमन शुभ चलिए बहुत लोग हैं
यार ओके सो लेट इट बी यहां पे अब आ जाते
हैं अब यहां पे सोडा तो हमने देख लिया
सोडा से ही सोडा से ही मिलता जुलता एक और
सर्विस है एक और वेबसाइट है जिसका नाम है
हंटर हंटर
हाउ इसको सर्च कीजिएगा हंटर हाउ यह एक
हंटर सर्च इंजन आप इसको बोल सकते हैं एंड
यह भी सडन की तरह ही लगभग काम करता है और
इसको भी यूज करने के लिए आपको इसकी क्वेरी
गाइड को पढ़नी पड़ेगी क्वेरी गाइड पर
क्लिक करेंगे आपको इसके फिल्टर्स मिलल
जाएंगे कैसे इसको यूज करना है थोड़ा सा
सडन से डिफरेंट है बट काइंड ऑफ उसी टाइप
का चीज है एंड उसी तरीके से ये भी काम
आपका करेगा जैसे आप यूज कर रहे थे सडन को
वैसे ही कुछ इसको भी यूज कीजिएगा अब यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं ये देखो ये देखो फिर
इसके क्वेरी गाइड को जैसे आईपी फ एड्रेस
के लिए अगर कोई आईपी फोर एड्रेस के लिए
अगर आपको कुछ सर्च करना है तो आप कुछ इस
तरीके से सर्च कर सकते हैं आईपी इक्वल्स
इक्वल एंड डबल कोट के अंदर में आपको यहां
पर आईपी एड्रेस दे देनी है एंड आपको यह
डिटेल्स जो भी उस आईपी से रिलेटेड चीज है
रिजल्ट्स है वो आपको दिखाएगा जैसे मुझे
चाहिए फ तो मैंने क्या किया पिंग न 4 पहले
दे देता हूं ए
फड कॉ तो यहां पर मुझे एक आईपी मिल गई यह
वाली मैंने इस आईपी को कॉपी कर लिया एंड
यहां पर मैं क्या करूंगा
आईपी इल इ इक्वल टू कॉलन डबल कोट मतलब जो
भी दे दो और यहां पे कंट्रोल v कर दिया
कॉलन क्लोज एंड एंटर कर दिया अब यहां पे
जो रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे आपको यहां पे इसके जो
रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे वो बेसिकली इसी आईपी से
रिलेटेड यानी
facebook.in जो ये एक यूआरएल मिली तो ये
यूआरएल अब इसकी डिटेल्स आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे पूरी डिटेल्स देखने के लिए आप
यहां पे व्यू डिटेल्स पे क्लिक करेंगे
आपको पूरी डिटेल जो है आपको यहां पे दिखनी
स्टार्ट हो जाएगी जस्ट वेट एंड
वच फिर से आ अगेन यह भी आपका पेड ही है
बिल्कुल फ्री में कुछ नहीं आने वाला है
यहां पे एक आपका फ्री जो सर्विस ये देते
हैं यह हमेशा फ्री जो रहता है इसमें आपको
लिमिटेड एक्सेस ही मिलता है ठीक है ना
लिमिटेड एक्सेस मिलता है यही है कि पोर्ट
कवरेज पूरी होती है आपके एंड आपको 10000
एपीआई रिजल्ट्स 30 दिन के मिलते हैं भैया
ये एक बहुत अच्छी चीज है मेरे को काफी
अच्छी इसमें लगती है ये चीज डेली क्वेरी
लिमिट 100 ही है जैसे आपका शान के अंदर
में है एंड यहां पे आप कुछ चीजें फ्री में
वो कर सकते हो जो शोडाउन में बेसिकली आप
नहीं कर सकते हो तो ये एक अच्छी चीज है तो
यू कैन ट्राई द फ्री वर्जन ऑफ दिस आराम से
इसका यह वाला यूज कर सकते हो ठीक है
हालांकि सडन के पास कुछ ज्यादा ही बड़ा
नेटवर्क है तो काफी लोग सडन को प्रेफर
करते हैं बट इसके साथ भी आप काफी काम अपना
चला सकते हो काफी कुछ कर सकते हो ठीक है
बस ये चीज है चलिए अब यहां पे हंटर
अ हरड हा को आप यूज कर सकते हैं इस तरीके
से डिटेल्स निकालने के लिए इसके अगेन आपके
सारे जो भी आपके क्वेरी क्वेरी गाइड्स से
आप देखिए डोमेन के लिए पर्टिकुलर ये आप
वेब टाइटल वही एटीटीपी टाइटल जो है वो वेब
टाइटल एटीटीपी टाइटल वाली या वेब टाइटल
वाली आप यह यूज़ कर सकते हैं वेब सर्वर के
लिए आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं स्टेटस कोड्स के
लिए यूज़ कर सकते हैं आईपी पोर्ट काउंट
करना है तो यह यूज़ कर सकते हैं
सर्टिफिकेट्स के लिए आप ये यूज कर सकते
हैं जैसे सर्टिफिकेट search.com अब इस
सर्टिफिकेट सब्जेक्ट के जो भी होंगे वो
सारे आपके यहां पे आपके रिजल्ट्स जो हैं
वो आपके आ जाएंगे तो यू कैन यूज द
hun.in आल्सो अब देखो मैं ये सब चीजें बता
इसलिए रहा हूं ना आपको अभी हमने सब डोमेन
इमेशन स्टार्ट नहीं किया ना नेक्स्ट क्लास
में मोस्ट प्रोबेबली हम कर देंगे लेकिन जब
हम आगे आगे बढ़ जाएंगे बग बाउंट में हम
बहुत सारी चीजें करेंगे एंड उस सब में मैं
जो भी इनिशियल्स बता रहा हूं आपको अभी
स्टार्टिंग के जो भी आपको इनिशियल में बता
रहा हूं स्टार्टिंग में बता रहा हूं वो सब
वी आर गोइंग टू यूज एंड यूटिलाइज
उन उन जो भी वो जो आपके जो भी आपके
स्टेप्स है उसमें हम यूटिलाइज करने वाले
हैं जो भी आपके जो स्टेप्स है हम उसमें
यूज करने वाले हैं इसलिए यह बहुत ज्यादा
ही जरूरी है बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है चलिए
ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है 100 19 लाइक्स
हैं अभी हमारे पास क्या लाइव एंड होने से
पहले 150 हो सकते हैं क्या मतलब एक्सपेक्ट
कर सकता हूं मैं इतने 150 लाइक्स देखते
हैं होता है कि नहीं आई डोंट नो मुझे डाउट
है बट ठीक है फिर भी आप चाहोगे तो हो
जाएगा चलिए ठीक है गॉट इट ओके तो ये आप
समझ में आ गया होगा ये आप यूज़ कीजिए अब
आप सडन पे आएंगे ना जब आप इसके फिल्टर्स
में तो इसके फिल्टर्स में और बहुत कुछ
मिलता है भैया बहुत कुछ है आपके इसके
फिल्टर्स में आप बहुत कुछ इसके फिल्टर से
फिल्टर करके जैसे मान लो मैं यहां पे करता
हूं एटीटीपी
डॉट टाइटल और हैक्ड मैं ये वाला फिल्टर
यूज करता हूं हैक्ड अब मैं एंटर करूंगा तो
जो भी हैक्ड वाले जो भी रिसोर्सेस अवेलेबल
है जो भी रिजल्ट्स आपको अवेलेबल है वो
आपको यहां पे मिल जाएंगे भैया तो ये देखिए
757 रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं हैक्ड बाय डेजर्ट
वरियर्स पता नहीं ये कोई डोमेन है
इन्होंने कंप्रोमाइज किया होगा लेट्स सी
ये देखिए ये कोई वेबसाइट है जो कि हैक हो
गई है एंड दिस इज य ये कौन सी ये वाली
आईपी है ये हैक्ड हुई है ठीक है इसको को
किसी ने हैक किया हुआ है यहां पे कुछ
वीडियो ऑडियो डाल दिए हुए हैं एंड
दैट्ची है कर्डी हैकर इन्होंने भी कुछ
किया है डिसेप्टिव साइट अहेड ये डिसेप्टिव
साइट है हैक्ड साइट है अगेन यहां पे एरर
नॉट फाउंड ठीक है एर नॉट फाउंड एरर नॉट
फाउंड एर नॉट फाउंड इस तरह से कुछ मिल रही
है अब
इसको ये तो दूसरी वाली है ना ये वाली
हैक्ड बाय मिस्टर टॉकी चंग पता नहीं क्या
टॉकी चंग है ये कौन सी है ये वाली ये
एडवांस चलते हैं यहां पे एक्सेप्ट रिस्क
एंड कंटिन्यू कर देते हैं तो यहां पे देखो
प्लीज से हेलो टर्स इन्होंने एक पॉप अप दे
दिया हुआ है डिजर्ट वरियर्स ऐसे करके आप
इस तरीके से भी फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं
मुझे एक पर्टिकुलर अचे वर्जन वाले
सर्विसेस चाहिए तो मैंने क्या करूंगा
अचे ठीक है अचे मैंने लिख दिया अब मुझे एक
पर्टिकुलर वर्जन का अचे का वर्जन का चाहिए
अचे वर्जन एंड मैंने यहां पे दे दिया 2.2
मान लो अचे वर्जन 2.25 या 2.2 जो भी देना
है दे दो यार 2 प यहां पे मैं दे देता हूं
2.2 अ 155 दे देते हैं वर्जन लेट्स सी द
रिजल्ट नो रिजल्ट
फाउंड
ओके लेट्स सी
द अब हम क्या देखते हैं यहां
पे ओके यहां पे देखो यहां पे क्या है
अपाचे अपाचे अपाचे वेर इज द अपाचे वेर इज
द अपाचे वे इज द अपाचे फिल्टर्स में देख
लेते हैं अपाचे अपाचे कहां गई अपाचे
भाई कंट्रोल एफ कर लेते हैं ए पीए सीएई
ओके देर इज नो हियर बट यहां पे मैंने एक
चीट शीट आपको दी थी चीट शीट मैंने आपको एक
चीट शीट दी थी ना चलो चीट शीट में चलते
हैं बग बाउंट वाले में यहां पे चीट शीट
में चल देते हैं एंड लेट्स वेट एक मैं इन
मैं इधर इधर जॉइन करा देता हूं जस्ट
वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट डस को होस्ट एंड खत्म
चलिए चलिए तो अब यहां पे चीटशीट मैंने दी
थी आपको तो ये चीटशीट ओपन करता हूं मैं अब
अब इस चीट शीट में आप देखो यहां पे इस चीट
शट में आपको अलग-अलग चीट शीट्स मिल जाएंगे
अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें आप फाइंड कर सकते हो
इसके अकॉर्डिंग तो इसमें आपको यहां पर
जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं आई एम गोइंग टू
[संगीत]
फाइंड चलो डायरेक्टली उसी को ओपन करते हैं
अचे डायरेक्टली अचे ही सर्च कर लेते हैं
वी आर गोइंग टू सर्च फॉर द सर्विसेस अचे
सो लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी सर्विसेस वी आर
गेटिंग ओके सो वी गॉट 19 लाख मतलब मिलियंस
में हमें सर्विसेस मिल रहे हैं जो अचे
यूज़ करते हैं बेसिकली य दो दोज हु आर
यूजिंग अचे अब मुझे चाहिए ऐसे सर्विसेस जो
अचे तो यूज़ कर रहे हैं ठीक है बट अब मुझे
चाहिए कंट्री
तो कंट्री मैं कंट्री क्या लगा दूंगा
इंडिया मुझे चाहिए इंडिया वाले लेट्स सी
इंडिया वाले कुछ आते हैं रिजल्ट्स कुछ
नहीं आए मुझे चाहिए चलो मैं यह यूएस वाला
लगा देता हूं भाई यूएस का लगा देते
हैं
एंड वी गॉट सम रिजल्ट्स ऑफ यूएस यर अब
इसमें मुझे कुछ और फिल्टर लगाने हैं ठीक
है अब मुझे कुछ और फिल्टर लगाने हैं मान
लो मेरे पास यहां पे फिल्टर्स है अब मैं
इसमें फिल्टर क्या लगा
दूंगा लेट्स
सी पोर्ट अ पोर्ट लगा सकते हैं ओस लगा
सकते हैं ओस ओस लगा सकते हैं मुझे
पर्टिकुलर अगर ओस से रिलेटेड चाहिए मान लो
मुझे चाहिए ओस अब मुझे ओस कौन सी चाहिए
भैया
विंडोज
विंडोज ठीक है एंड कंट्री यूएस तो मैं इस
तरीके का फिल्टर यूज़ कर सकता हूं ओ विज
एंड कंट्री यूएस अब इस तरीके से मुझे यह
रिजल्ट्स आपको यहां पे मिल जाएंगे उस
पर्टिकुलर कंट्री के उस पर्टिकुलर ओएस से
रिलेटेड जो भी सर्विसेस है वो सब सर्विसेस
जो हैं अब आपको यहां पे वो मिल जाएंगे ठीक
है इस तरीके से यू कैन फाइंड आउट एंड यू
कैन यूज़ द सडन तो सडन को इस तरीके से
यूज़ करने का यह तरीका है बहुत ही शानदार
तरीका है सडन बहुत ही एक शानदार टूल है
जिसका आप यूज़ करना जरूर चाहेंगे सडन के
साथ-साथ यू कैन यूज़ दिस वन आल्सो जो
मैंने आपको टूल बताया हंट ड हाउ इसके जगह
पर आप इसके साथ सेंसेस नाम की टूल भी यूज
कर सकते हैं यू कैन यूज दिस सेंसेस दिस इ
आल्सो काइंड ऑफ सर्च इंजन यह सर्च सर्च
सेंस आ यह भी एक सर्च इंजन है जिसको आप
यूज किया जा सकता है यहां पर आप यूज कर
सकते हैं यू कैन ट्राई एंड यूज व्हाट एवर
यू वांट ठीक है
फ मैंने होस्ट नेम सर्च किया यहां पे आई
एम सर्चिंग होस्ट
नेम
इट विल गिव द रिजल्ट्स ओके चलिए रिजल्ट दे
रहा है तब तक आपको एक और बताता हूं जम आई
आप यह भी सर्च कर सकते हैं इट्स ल् सो
लाइक इसको आप एक सर्च इंजन मान सकते हैं
साइबर स्पेस सर्च
इंजन साइबर स्पेस का एक यह भी सर्च इंजन
है जिसको आप यूज कर सकते हैं जम आई यह भी
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है यू कैन यूज दिस
आल्सो ओके सो लेट्स ओपन
इट तो यह कुछ सर्विसेस है बट इन सब में
सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर आपका शडा है आपका जूम
आई भी यूज होता है सेंसेस भी यूज होता है
आपका हंटर हाउ भी यूज होता है सो व्हाट
एवर यू कैन यूज अब मुझे बताइए ये सडन को
जब मैं आगे बग बाउंट में यूज करूंगा फॉर
फर्द थिंग्स तो आपको कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं
होगी पहले मुझे ये बता दीजिए जब मैं सूडान
को बग बाउंट में यूज करूंगा आगे के
क्लासेस में तो आपको समझ में आएगा कि मैं
सडन में क्या कर रहा हूं आपको ये तो समझ
में आ जाएगा कि मैं कैसे कर रहा हूं ये
सारी चीजें क्लियर हो जाएंगी ना भाई मुझे
बता दीजिए जल्दी जल्दी बताइए जल्दी बताइए
जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी लेट मी नो फास्ट
गाइस प्लीज लेट मी नो फास्ट
एवरीवन लेट मी नो समझ में आ जाएगा
आपको क्लियर रहेगा सोडा की सोडा की अच्छा
ये बताइए सडन की इनफ आपको आज क्लास लगी ना
पूरी इनफ आपको आपको फिल्टर से पता चल गया
आपको फिल्टर का बता दिया आपको कैसे किस
तरीके से आप सडन के इस तरह के जो फिल्टर्स
है इसको यूज कर सकते सते हैं जो हमारे पास
फिल्टर्स यहां पे पड़े हुए हैं डान के ये
सारे फिल्टर्स को आप यूज़ कर कर के
रिजल्ट्स फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं आप एक-एक
फिल्टर को रिमूव कर सकते हैं हाइ फन लगा
के उन उन रिजल्ट्स को आप सॉर्ट आउट कर
सकते हैं ठीक है एसटीटीपी स्टेटस के
अकॉर्डिंग टाइटल के अकॉर्डिंग वफ के
अकॉर्डिंग सब कुछ कर सकते हैं एवरीथिंग यू
कैन यूज राइट तो क्लियर आपको
हुआ क्लियर हो गया ना हां फिर भी मैं
बताता तो रहूंगा ही उसका टेंशन आपको नहीं
लेना है आपको मैं बताता ही रहूंगा उसकी
टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है ठीक है फिर भी
आगे भी जब भी जब आपको जरूरत पड़ेगी आई विल
आई विल कीप अ आई विल कीप टेलिंग यू ऑल द
थिंग्स आई विल कीप गाइडिंग यू अबाउट
एवरीथिंग्स तो उसके लिए आपको टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है ठीक है बिल्कुल टेंशन नहीं लेनी
है उसके लिए वो मैं गाइड करता रहूंगा उसकी
टेंशन आप मत लो ठीक है आई कीप गाइडिंग और
ये सोशल मीडिया हैंडल्स पे आप कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं पहली बात दूसरी बात मैं आपको
बार-बार बोल रहा हूं कि हमारा जो डि
फ्रक्स अकेडमी पप पे जो हमारा फ्री कोर्स
है भैया उसको जरूर से जरूर जवाइन कीजिए
वहां बहुत जितने रिसोर्सेस हैं आपको उसी
पे मिलेंगे ये जो आपको क्लास दिख रहा है
नाना भैया ये जो आपको फ्री फ्री ऊपर में
फ्री साइबर सिक्योरिटी रिसोर्स इसको जवाइन
कर लेना है इसके कंटेंट वाले में आइएगा तो
सब कुछ आपको मिलेगा भैया जो आपको फ्री में
रिसोर्सेस जो भी हैं सारे यहां पे डाउट
सेशंस होंगे लाइव क्लासेस में देखो पिछला
डाउट सेशन हुआ था वो भी मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं ये देखो बग बाउंट डाउट सेशन 49
मिनट के हुए थे ये भी आपको इसमें मिल
जाएगा सब चीजें आपको इसी फ्री वाले सेशंस
में मिल फ्री वाले इसमें मिल जाएंगी ठीक
है सब कुछ आपको यहां पे मिलेगा तो ये जरूर
से जरूर आप ऐप को इंस्टॉल करके लॉग इन
करके इसमें जवाइन कर लीजिएगा जो इंटरनेशनल
स्टूडेंट्स हैं वो क्रेडिट कार्ड ही यूज
कर सकते हैं इंटरनेशनल उनका लोकल क्रेडिट
कार्ड यूज हो जाएगा व उससे कर पाएंगे
जवाइन दूसरी चीज कि जो भी ऐसे लोग हैं जो
आईओएस यूजर्स हैं उनके लिए मैं एक चीज बता
देता हूं जो भी आईओएस यूजर्स है दे कैन गो
टू
द वह आप क्या करना अकेडमी पर चले जाना इस
पे इस पर चले आना यहां पर ठीक है आईओएस
यूजर्स के लिए मैं ओनली बता रहा हूं यह
आपके स्टेप आप आना एंड यहां से आप गेट
कोर्स करना यहां पर आप गेट कोर्स करना गेट
दिस कोर्स पर क्लिक करना अपना नेम ईमेल
आईडी मोबाइल नंबर ये स्टेट डाल के ओटीपी
से वेरीफाई कर लेना फोन नंबर एंड उसके बाद
आप जैसे ही इनरोल कर लोगे आप यहीं से लॉग
इन कर लेना लॉग इन करोगे तो यहां पे आप
अपने फोन नंबर से लॉग इन करके आप लॉग इन
होके वेब पे एक्सेस कर पाओगे ए एप की आपको
मतलब आईओएस पप की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी
क्योंकि आईओएस पप अभी हमारा लच हुआ नहीं
है वो होगा तो आप वहां से भी फिर सेम
कोर्स को सेम नंबर से लॉगइन करके कर पाओगे
ठीक है तो ज्यादा इसकी टेंशन नहीं लेनी है
समझ में आ गया भैया ये तो क्लियर हो गया
होगा ना और और हां एक चीज और आपको एक चीज
बता रहा हूं हमारी डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक की
लाइव ट्रेनिंग आने वाली है जिसमें आपके
ट्रेनर जो होंगे ही इज अ सीईए एंड
सीएचएफआई एंड डीसीएसपी आल्सो एंड ही विल
बी ट्रेनिंग यू फॉर द नेक्स्ट थ्री मंथ्स
लाइव ट्रेनिंग होगी मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल
ट्रेनिंग होने वाली है आपकी अ कौन सी
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक की जहां पे आप पूरी
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक को एक्सप्लोर करेंगे
हैंड्स ऑन प्रैक्टिकल एंड आप जब ट्रेनिंग
कर लेंगे तो आप इससे रिलेटेड जो इंटरनेशनल
एग्जामिनेशन आप समझ रहे मैं क्या बोलना
चाह रहा हूं उसको भी आप क्रैक कर पाएंगे
उस लेवल की आपकी वो ट्रेनिंग होने वाली है
उस ट्रेनिंग के बारे में ज्यादा आपको
जानना है यू कैन कांटेक्ट अस ऑन आवर नंबर
कौन से नंबर पे कांटेक्ट कर सकते हैं भैया
यह हमारी वेबसाइट पे दिया हुआ है क्यों
मैं यहां पे बताऊं मेरी वेबसाइट पे यहां
पे पूरी दी हुई है यार
whatsapp2 इसपे
[संगीत]
का हैंडल है ट
ऑफिशल अंडर स्कोटी एन यह वाला हैंडल है आप
इस पर कांटेक्ट मैसेज करिएगा एंड एक आज से
कल में आपको रिप्लाई आ जाएगा ठीक है यह टे
ग्राल ओके सो गाइस ट्स ल ट्स ल फॉर टुडे
ओके ओके
तो एंड हा होमवर्क में क्या है भाई
होमवर्क में क्या है सुन लो होमवर्क में
क्या है भैया फेस आप जो भी टारगेट है जो
आपका यह जो टास्क है आपको मैं टास्क तो
मैं देता ही हूं यार टास्क देख लो टास्क
जो है
ना टास्क क्या है देख
लो चूज योर टारगेट चूज योर टारगेट जैसे
मैंने अपना फब टारगेट चूज किया हुआ है ना
आप भी अपना टारगेट चूज
करो सर्च एंड फाइंड एंड फाइंड
एवरीथिंग रिलेटेड टू दैट
टारगेट फ्रॉम शोडाउन
एंड हंटर डट
इन दोनों का यूज करना है एंड आपको जितनी
भी चीजें हैं उसको प्रिपेयर करना है उसको
आपको फाइंड करना है प्रिपेयर अ प्रिपेयर
स्प्रेडशीट स्प्रेडशीट या एक्सेल शीट ऑफ
योर फाइंडिंग्स ऑफ योर फाइंडिंग्स और मेक
अ नोट इन इन नोशन या वन नोशन में कर लो या
वन नोट में कर लो या
कीप में कर लो व्हाट एवर या जो भी जो भी
आपको नोट मेकिंग एप्लीकेशन है उसको आप यूज
कीजिए एंड यह काम करके लाइए दिस इज
योर
टास्क तीन स्टेप्स में आपको टास्क दिए हैं
मैंने यह टास्क आप कंप्लीट कीजिए एंड जो
भी हो जाए आप उसको अपलोड कीजिए आप अपने
टास्क को जो भी आपका लिस्ट बने आपका जो
फाइल बन रहा है उसको
goeden.in ठीक है
दैट्ची सारी चीज आ जाएंगी
ओके चलिए 130 हो गए लाइक्स 150 तो नहीं
हुए बट 130 हो गए थैंक यू सो मच तो आई होप
आपको आज का सेशन इंटरेस्टिंग लगा होगा
नेक्स्ट सेशंस में हम सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन
को स्टार्ट करेंगे और भी बहुत सारी चीजें
करेंगे गिट हप रिकॉर्न करेंगे पता नहीं
क्या-क्या करेंगे तो दिल थाम के बैठे रहिए
एंड नेक्स्ट सेशंस का वेट कीजिए काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें और आने वाली है एंड आई
होप कि आपको आज के सेशन में भी मजा आया
होगा चलिए मजा आया होगा तो अपने दोस्तों
के बीच सेशन को शेयर कीजिए यही एक बहुत
बड़ा सपोर्ट है मेरे लिए आपके साइड से
दैट्ची फ्री कोर्स आपको इस तरह के इतने इन
डेफ्ट में अगर कोई
youtube1